з директорату професійної освіти пані
Наталія атаманенко я там буду довертати
свій ноутбук і ми з хвилини на хвилину
чекаємо генерального директора пані
Ірину Шумик також від дпн-ресурс
адміністратора державної бази з питань
освіти є дебо
присутній пані Марина пасльон і пан
Віктор анохін
пані Марино ви здається мені можете свій
мікрофон самі включити Ану спробуйте
прекрасно
[музика]
Так я нагадаю для тих хто приєднався
пізніше для всіх інших користувачів
окрім доповідачів сьогоднішнього
вебінару можливість користуватися
мікрофоном вимкнена для того щоб задати
запитання а такий блок буде в кінці
вебінару вам потрібно підняти руку
Це буде виглядати отак Та знизу як
кнопочка я побачив вас в переліку
контактів в переліку учасників і тоді
зможу включити вам мікрофон
[оплески]
ще раз повторю що вебінар записується
вебінар записується Як локально так і
транслюється на офіційній сторінці
мон в YouTube за тим же посиланням яке
вказано в листі ви зможете переглянути в
будь-який момент запис цього вебінару ну
і
мабуть почнемо І так сьогодні ми з вами
говоримо
я думав лише для лише для мене
хвилююча тема і так сказати
як це правильно сказати
[музика]
ми ми говоримо про вступ про вступну
кампанію
Так пані Тетяна кіна або щось хоче
важливе запитати або тестує функцію
давайте її
запитаємо
користуватися та
Ага це було тестування Гаразд не встиг Я
включити мікрофон добре друзі Значить ми
говоримо про вступну про вступну
кампанію
2023 року До закладів професійної освіти
і відповідно які зміни реалізовані в
програмному забезпеченні є деба
в цьому році і що нам з вами вперше да
інші рівні освіти вища освіта фахово
передвищу освіта роблять це трохи
давніше А ми ці зміни реалізували цього
року і цього року вперше реалізована
можливість здобувачам
абітурієнтам подавати заяви
електронній формі через кабінет їдемо і
також додана можливість
адміністраторам єдеба створювати заяви
на вступ до здобувачів в електронній
формі в кабінетах закладів Давайте я зі
свого боку якби базові речі тільки
нагадаю а після цього передам слово наші
головній спікерці
значить
програма
Я не бачу змісту її повторювати все ви
її отримав отримали
отримали в листах єдине що ви бачите так
що в нас там з 10 трішки пізніше почали
там до 11-15 це безпосередньо
презентації
що
стосується роботи з різними розділами
кабінету
і відповідно великі блок часу з 11-15 до
12 ми
передбачили на ваші запитання відповіді
Але
я думаю що ми будемо працювати рівно до
тих пір поки запитання ваші
не закінчиться
так проте де брати новини і звідки
черпати інформацію оскільки як я вже
сказав цього року ми вперше реалізуємо
таку можливість відповідно від вас
знаходить багато запитань багато
зауважень на якісь запитання Ми
відправляємо роз'яснення а десь дійсно є
там
збої чи некоректно реалізовані функції
чи неправильно описане технічне завдання
програмістом Відповідно ми це Стараємося
якомога швидше виправити і
проінформувати вас про це про те де саме
ви можете
почитати найсвіжіші новини Це ось будь
ласка посилання а також у ваших оскільки
Я запрошував саме адміністраторів є або
у ваших кабінетах зліва меню ж це сама
верхня кнопочка новини є Де Бо там
завжди найсвіжіша
інформація так у мене ще 30 людей тих
хто
пізніше зараз я їх впущу і продовжу
поїхали далі значить ну просто просто
нагадати вам та якими
нормативно-правовими документами ми
послуговуємось працюючи як з єде бо так
і
будь-яку комунікуючи за абітурієнтами
на слайді читати не буду не думаю що для
вас тут щось нового
так само
ми послуговуємось
ліцензійними умовами
положенням про єдину державну електронну
базу з питань освіти і типовими
правилами
прийому до закладів
професійний професійно-технічної освіти
які у нас коли будуть зареєстровані нова
редакція
найближчий час найближчим часом
мати ще з цього боку новини Ну і
очевидно що ми
комунікуємо з вами
листовій формі та щура щоразу коли
це я всім завжди кажу щоби закривали
свою чат-бокси знизу А сам цього не
зробив буває значить
ми комунікуємо з вами листами щоразу
коли ми коли готові якісь нові оновлені
чи коли в нас є якісь роз'яснення
Ми відправляємо їх в першу чергу на
департаменти освіти Якщо нам треба
комунікувати і донести вам якусь
інформацію Ми також підключаємо
навчально-методичні центри до цього
[музика]
І що І у нас пані Ірина Шумик є
сколікома Ірина Володимирівна Ми
сьогодні працюємо лише зі звуком а
камера Тут тому з вступним вітальним
словом Я запрошую до почесного стільця з
боку
генеральну директорку директорату
професійної освіти
пані ринок шумів прошу Добрий день
шановні колеги я не буду дуже довго
затриму вати тому що розумію що краще
пройтися по деталях які сьогодні
презентують Мої колеги але власне
хотілося б сказати що цифровізація
добралася і до професійно-технічної
освіти і не просто добралася в частині
передачі певної комп'ютерної техніки а
власне ми переходимо до цифровізації
процесів різних процесів освітнього
середовища яке ми маємо в процесі Які
взагалі передують початку надання
освітньої послуги і власне це ми робимо
для того щоб максимально спростити життя
всім для того щоб дійсно дані якими ми
оперуємо в системі професійної освіти
вони були актуальні вони були валідовані
і Власне вони мали змогу бути
презентованими і бути публічними Я дуже
гарно і добре пам'ятаю коли тільки
починалося підключення закладів
професійно-технічної освіти до
єддо і я пам'ятаю як це було не просто
скільки було зауважень скільки було
неточностей Я думаю що тут колеги Отакі
є там десь посміхаються теж дуже гарно
пам'ятають і знають що будь-яке
нова ініціатива вона Ну спочатку
пробуксовує тому що Треба поставити цей
потяг на рейки але потім коли вже це
ініціатива реалізована ми розуміємо
наскільки вона є зручною і як може бути
краще швидше оперативніше і так далі і
тому подібне власне ми минулого року
реагуючи на виклики
пов'язані з повномасштабним повторенням
і війною в Україні а також пов'язані з
тим що великий відсоток наших учнів
потенційних учнів мігрують Звернулися до
наших партнерів до донорів бо ви знаєте
бюджетного фінансування немає з тим щоби
нам допомогли в розробленні електронного
кабінету для вступу і Спочатку ми
задумували його просто і як такого
оболонку власне такий певний зручний
інтерфейс для подання заяви але з часом
працюючий розуміючи що це може бути
гарне гарним інструментом управлінським
у нас не Протягом цього трошки більше
року допрацювали декілька етапів тому що
я кажу це все Не просто ще треба знайти
відповідні кошти на роботу фахівців і
сьогодні наші колеги з державного
підприємства Інфоресурс і Олексій з
команди підтримки реформ вам презентують
Як сьогодні це працює Я не можу сказати
що в нас все
на сьогодні після тестування бо воно
було проведено протягом травня та і ось
тут червня цього року ми протягом
тестування вже виявили декілька таких
проблемних питань і зараз команда моїх
колег працює над їх вирішенням але в нас
з 1 липня стартує вступна кампанія в нас
дискотека теж Інколи буває ми тут всі
разом Просто в нас такий Open Space
працюємо і в нас стартує
мовно-офіційно ми собі так межі на рівні
Міністерства на національному рівні
визначаємо з 1 липня вступна кампанія і
нам надзвичайно важливо щоб
ви всі були теж готові для того щоб цим
інструментом покористуватися цього року
ми максимально намагатимуся адаптувати в
нас є певний час в нас є можливості і в
нас не не тільки
лімітовані певні
дати та пов'язані зі вступом це не
фахове перевищення освіта тому я думаю
що треба спокійно сприймати
майбутні зміни приймати те що можливо ми
колеги які на цій працювали зробили ще
не все ідеально але точно розуміти що ми
це доопрацюємо в процесі І власне
Я сподіваюсь на наступний рік взагалі
забудемо що таке паперова подання
документів а все буде автоматизовано
тому що ми рухаємося далі рухаємося до
того щоб
бази даних на рівні держави між собою
дружили щоб було забезпечено відповідний
обмін інформацією в тому числі
персоніфікований колеги не будуть
забирати дуже багато часу я
точно ага бачу зараз питання зараз я я
відповім Якщо зможу Не Galaxy A30 S Якщо
у вас є питання будь ласка ви маєте
можливість зараз задати його
Ми пробуємо включити якщо Galaxy A30 S
там бачу Наталії не може включитися це
означає що в нас є ще не все гаразд
Digital Skills і не тільки фахівці які
працюють над розробленнях різних
електронних сервісів
інколи щось роблять не так пані Наталя
будь ласка Вітаю пані Ірина Підкажіть
будь ласка ось таке запитання
як чи лімітовно який віковий
бар'єр для прийняття на
для кваліфікованого робітника чи є там
якийсь вік
відповідає тому що ми стикаємося знаєте
з подібними не стільки питаннями вже
потім випадками коли десь щось було
порушено на сьогодні в чинному
законодавстві України відсутні вікові
бар'єри Та ми ми неї чистим ми не
забороняємо там десь комусь вступати але
є певні
законодавчо ви компанії відповідно
процедури прийому на навчання так от
якщо ми кажемо про дорослих осіб нам
чітко треба розуміти на який вид
підготовки ми кого можемо прийняти якщо
людина вже має певну професійну
кваліфікацію Тобто це не просто
випускник школи який після школи чи яка
ніде не вчилися і Ніде не працювали як
тільки в трудовій книжці навіть без
здобуття і без продовження навчання
після школи з'являється певна
кваліфікація та людина десь була
операція влаштована і в процесі трудової
діяльності отримала кваліфікацію такі
люди вже не можуть бути зараховані на
первинну професійну підготовку якщо до
нас призвертаються дорослі які хочуть
продовжити навчання Ми повинні розуміти
що це групи
професійно-технічного навчання є правда
виняток який ми маємо в законі Про
освіту це у тому випадку якщо ми кажемо
про дорослих які повертаються та або
приходять на перепідготовку
і відповідають тим вимогам які на
сьогодні виписані можуть бути
дозараховані на ці вільні місця
замовлення але тут теж звертайте увагу
ми зараз не говоримо про учнів там чи
про групи на базі дев'яти класів Ну тому
що Зрозуміло Та що вони не можуть всі
люди вчитися три роки якщо їм треба
здобути просто чисто професію або
перекваліфікацію тому Скажімо так
напряму особі Якщо їй 65 або більше Або
менше трошки рочків приходить ви
відмовите не можете але якщо людина Каже
Я так хочу вчитися а там в трудовій
книжці вже університети
купа робочих місць то цим людям я вас
дуже прошу і звертаю на це увагу просто
спокійно показуйте що ось є
законодавство є первинна професійна
підготовка є потім перепідготовка
підвищення кваліфікації що для них є
відповідні
Зрозуміло дякую вам велике Galaxy A30 ви
там пробували включитися була спроба
звуку у вас ще
залишається та прошу
я думаю що неактуально якщо у вас
залишилося Запитання Ви матимете змогу
написати його в
чатик так давайте ще начати відреагую
там перед цим
жалілись Люди що ви чуєте Луну що звук
подвійний Напишіть будь ласка в чат плюс
якщо є Луна і мінус якщо зі звуком все
добре
Так я у одного користувача бачу плюс у
всіх інших бачив мінуси Дякую більше ним
Так
перевірте налаштування я би сказала що
тут потрібно перевірити налаштування
вашого відтворення звуку Тому що інколи
якщо у вас
увімкнені додаткові пристрої може може
фонити особливо якщо кілька користувачів
одночасно дивляться цей Zoom на
паралельних
паралельно добре значить Дорогі колеги
тепер Я запрошую до слова пані Марину
пасльон із державного підприємства
Інфоресурс власне з основною
презентацією Прошу пані Марина
всім добрий день перше ніж
проводити демонстрацію нашого
функціоналу Я б хотіла вам нагадати на
джерела інформації які вам будуть
корисними по-перше Я вважаю що будуть
вам корисними сайт інфоресурси де в нас
є розділ інструкції і ви можете
отримати інформацію щодо різних розділів
є бо і окремо У нас є інструкція щодо
вступної кампанії в закладі професійної
технічної освіти
наступне Я дуже вас прошу
передивляйтеся інформацію на сайті вступ
є Де bo.gov.ua тут окрема блок для
вступників До закладів професійної
професійно-технічної освіти Ось
натискаєте на кнопку інформацію для
вступника і ви можете побачити і основні
терміни і інформаційні матеріали які нам
підготовлені відео роз'яснення і
посилання на нормативні документи
з цим все ця інформація може
доповнюватись оновлюватися будь ласка
відслідковуйте
тепер почнемо власне нашу презентацію
розділи за якими ми сьогодні попрацюємо
було повідомлення в матеріалах до
конференції
щодо того де розміщена інструкція я вам
розказала рекомендоване браузер Google
Chrome вхід до бази за посиланням від
двох.ua вся інформація щодо для
вступника на сайті вступ є де bogo.ua
тепер Давайте почнемо щодо
власної роботи з
модулями є debo я вам покажу як це
виглядає в базі це буде найбільш
ефективною я так вважаю Дивіться ви
Заходите в базу обираєте розділ вступна
кампанія і спочатку необхідно щоб
закладом було завантажено правила
прийому для цього ви обираєте
відповідний модуль правила прийому
натискаєте активні дії додати і обираєте
сферу освіти якщо заклад та освіти готує
І наприклад в сфері фаху передвищу
освіти і в сфері професійної технічної
освіти то такі правила прийому
завантажуються окремими блоками
натискаємо
професійно-професійна технічна освіта і
додати далі обираємо запис натискаємо
додати редагувати файл обираємо власний
файл і завантажуємо відео
і натискаємо закрити все правила прийому
завантаженого от відповідно позначка нам
про це свідчить тут вказано коли було
ким завантажено наступна інформація яку
обов'язково необхідно заповнити це
інформація щодо приймальних комісій
натискаємо активні дії додати приймальну
комісію заповнюємо блок
Подивіться будь ласка на поле мобільний
номер відповідального секретаря Справа в
тому що це інформація вона не десь не
відображається на загальних ресурсах але
вона вкрай важлива коли необхідно
оперативно зв'язатися з представником
приймальної комісії закладу
телефон вводяться в форматі + 38
тому дуже просимо його вводити
адреса електронної пошти телефон комісії
він може відрізнятись від телефону
секретаря і зверніть увагу ще на поля
дату початку роботою дати Закінчення
роботи у приймальної комісії чому
важливо ці поля заповнити тому що
у випадку відсутності цієї інформації
інформація про приймальну комісія не
буде відображатись в реєстрі суб'єктів
освітньої діяльності тобто інформація
про заклад буде А щодо цього інформація
буде відсутня ви потім будете на це ж
власний жалітись
і натискаємо зберегти інформація про
приймальну комісію внесена за потреби Ви
також можете внести інформацію про
відбіркову комісію знову ж таки
натискаєте оптимідії додати відбіркового
комісії так само заповнюйте цю
інформацію
повністю панологія
Так це заповнили тепер наступний блок
конкурсні пропозиції
конкурсні пропозиції можна створювати на
ліцензії наявні в закладі освіти
передивитись ліцензію закладу власне ви
знаєте до У вас є ліцензія але все ж
таки ви можете в розділі закладу освіти
і ліцензії за сферами освіти
Обирайте відповідний
розділ таблицю і передивляйтесь які
ліцензії в сфері професійно-технічної
освіти наявні закладів
створюються конкурсні пропозиції тільки
на первинну професійну підготовку будь
ласка зверніть на це увагу Ну власне
переходимо до створення ліцензії
конкурсних пропозиціях
в розділі вступна кампанія обираємо
модуль конкурсні пропозиції
натискаємо активні дії створити
назву конкурсної пропозиції варто
обирати враховуючи професії на які вона
створюється і також доцільно вказувати
базу вступу
пошук Подивіться будь ласка конкурсні
пропозиції у нас створюються як на
ліцензії на одну професію тобто на
монопрофесію так на інтегровані
Також ми можемо створити і конкурсну
пропозицію на кілька моно ліцензій на
моно професію Ну ось наприклад
ми вводимо код ліцензії
ID ліцензії ось ось цей показник
у нас підтягується випадна список з цим
і далі підтягується одразу вся
інформація
вказана в ліцеї - це рівень освіти вид
підготовки тощо також одразу вказується
ліцензований обсяг Який Ну відповідно до
цієї ліцензії ми бачимо що у нас це
зварник Тобто ми можемо назвати ліцензію
конкурсну пропозицію зварник
і вказати базу вступу
відповідно тут ми також обираємо базу
вступу форму навчання після цього ми
вказуємо обсяг на бюджет на контракт ми
можемо не використовувати весь обсяг на
Цю конкурсну пропозицію можемо вказати
частину з неї але не більше ніж вказано
в цьому полі обсяг на контракт в нас
може бути 0 вартість навчання відповідно
також може бути поле вступний я
Випробування Це текстове поле ви
вказуєте через кому ті вступні
випробування які є в вашому закладі
освіти
це може бути співбесіда це ну відповідно
правил прийому закладу освіти
А якщо потрібно на вказану професію який
додаткові документи аніж ті що
передбачені за замовчуванням в кабінеті
вступника особа може додати медичну
довідку із додаток до документа про
освіту якщо в вашому правилами прийому
передбачено ще якісь додатковий документ
ви натискаєте відповідно
позначку і вказуєте Власне цей документ
якщо не потрібно ви її не використовуєте
далі дата початку навчання Зверніть будь
ласка увагу на ці поля в залежності від
основи вступу в період навчання може
бути різний
максимально на базі повної загальної
середньої освіти це не більше двох років
на основі базової середньої освіти не
більше 4 років а період навчання ви
вказуєте в повних роках і місяцях Ну ось
наприклад ми заповнимо що дата початку
навчання З 1 вересня нехай випуск
наприклад передбачено 25 30 червня тоді
термін навчання Ми вказуємо один рік і
10 місяців
тут ми вказуємо дату початку прийому
заяв і закінчення прийому заяв Ну нехай
це будуть наступні дати
Зверніть будь ласка увагу на наступні
поля ну обов'язково вказуєте приймальну
комісію
додатковий набір Це ці поля не
обов'язково одразу заповнювати при
створенні конкурсної пропозиції ви їх
можете заповнити на будь-якому етапі
вступної кампанії пізніше коли ви дійсно
будете мати необхідну вам інформацію
після внесення всієї інформації ми
натискаємо що підтвердження внесення
конкурсної пропозиції і натискаємо
зберегти
в даному випадку так трошки ми вже маємо
таку конкурсну пропозицію
Відповідно ми не можемо створити з тими
самими параметрами
[музика]
дивимось створені конкурсні пропозиції
ось в цьому закладі Як ви можете
побачити є конкурсні пропозиції на
монопрофесій і на інтеграцію для того
щоб створити конкурсну пропозицію на
якусь інтегровану ліцензію Ми обираємо
ось цю ознаку і вводимо ID конкурсну
id-ліцензії
на кілька професій
Ось вона у нас підтягується і подивіться
будь ласка одразу У нас є назва однієї
професії і назва другої професії Також
ми можемо створити конкурсну пропозицію
створити так звану штучну інтеграцію на
кілька ліцензій на монопрофесі це
робиться наступним чином Ми обираємо усю
першу позначку і
поступово обираємо кілька ліцензій
у нас з'являються після заповнення код
запису ліцензії 2
і так далі
порядок дій щодо заповнення решти полів
такий самий як я вам вже і показала
Також ми можемо створювати конкурсні
пропозиції на ліцензії реорганізованого
закладу освіти який було приєднано до
вашого закладу
ось ми бачимо в даному закладі освіти є
вісім ліцензій з певними
ID А ми можемо ось в основних даних у
нас є інформація що заклад освіти має
право протягом 6 місяців часу
реорганізації користуватись ліцензіями
іншого закладу освіти відповідно тут ми
вводимо
ID ліцензії реорганізованого закладу і
бачите вони у нас підтягуються Ми так
само можемо за ними створити штучну
інтеграцію за потреби тощо
наступний порядок дій такий самий як я
вам вже і показала
Зверніть будь ласка увагу що є
комбінації які
неприпустимі на сьогодні для створення
штучних інтеграцій у наприклад ви не
можете створити конкурсну пропозицію на
кілька інтегрованих ліцей ви не можете
створити конкурсну пропозицію в
комбінації однієї інтегрована однією
монопрофесій вона можете маючи ліцензії
на інтеграцію створити конкурсну
пропозицію на якусь моно професію
мати це будь ласка на увазі
після того як у нас створення конкурсної
пропозиції Вони внесені Зверніть будь
ласка увагу що конкурсна пропозиція яка
має ось таку ознаку означає що вона
внесена і вона буде відображатись в
електронному кабінеті вступника власне
чому листа амон було
запропоновано внести конкурсну
пропозицію до кінця червня в зв'язку з
тим що з 1 липня розпочинають роботи
електронні кабінети вступника і з 1
липня вони можуть подавати заяви тому
якщо ваша конкурсної пропозиції не
будуть внесені вони їх просто не
побачать тому бажано створити конкурсні
пропозиції до 1 липня
наступним заяви вступників тобто маючи
вже створені конкурсні пропозиції ми
можемо створити заяву вступника подану
вам в паперовому вигляді для цього в
модулі заяви вступників по натискаєте
активні дії створити паперову заяву Далі
ви здійснюєте пошук фізичну особу
ми вводимо дату народження
я користуюсь тестовими даними тому
співпадіння з будь-якою особою це буде
випадковістю
далі вводимо тільки номер документа про
освіту
і натискаємо пошук і Якщо нам знаходить
особу ми натискаємо брату якщо особу не
знаходить і ви вірно ввели вказані дані
Ви маєте створити попередню картку
фізичного особу ну це процедура вам
знайома я не буду на неї з зупинятися
натискаємо обрати далі ми вказуємо номер
вступника
[музика]
можна вказати додатковий номер далі ми
здійснюємо пошук конкурсної пропозиції
ми це можемо робити за назвою
а можемо натиснути на лупу і побачити
всі конкурсні пропозиції які доступні в
закладі освіти відповідно вказаних
параметрів тобто відповідно
документа з яким особа подає заяву
обираємо якусь конкурсну пропозицію
і заповнюємо далі вказуєте номер
особової справи
вказуєте джерело фінансування тобто
особа може обрати вступає на бюджет
контракт або вступає на бюджет але також
згоден навчатись на контракті
Далі ви сюди не завантажуєте жодних
документів Я маю на увазі медична
довідка чи документ додаток документа
про освіту ви тільки
вказуєте його наявність тобто якщо особа
не надає вам таку такий документ Ви
ставите позначку І вказуєте причину А
так само щодо додатку Тобто ви ставите
позначку І вказуєте причину відсутності
і вступника цього документа Також тут
можете вказати чи потребує вступник
місця гуртожитку Зверніть будь ласка
увагу тут є статус заяви зареєстровано у
закладі освіти тобто заява поданах
паперовому вигляді перше статус має
зареєстровано в закладі освіти трошки
пізніше ми зупинимося взагалі на
статусах але це будь ласка для себе
запам'ятайте наступний блок - це так
звані пільгові категорії тобто особа
може бути зарахована по закорсом якщо
вона має документи що підтверджує в неї
наявність однієї з вказаних пільг
особа може бути одночасно кілька пільг
також наступним блок - це першочергове
зарахування так само особа має
підтвердити вам наявність вказаних пір
після заповнення всіх полів
ви натискаєте зареєструвати
зареєстровані заяви у вас будуть блоці
заяви ПТУ
Зверніть будь ласка увагу заяви подані з
електронного кабінету вступника мають
ось таку позначку це заява подані в
електронному вигляді тепер трішки уваги
щодо
статусів заяв
зверніть увагу заяви подані з
електронного кабінету вступника мають
перше статус зареєстровано в єдину після
цього ви можете Таку заяву переглянути і
відправити встановити і статус потребує
уточнення вступником тобто Можливо
там відсутня медична довідка Яка є
обов'язковою чи ще щось далі вступник
реагує на ваші зауваження і ця заява
повертається в
заклад Ну тобто вона набуває статусу
знов зареєстровано в єдину після цього
заклад може становити статус
зареєстровано в закладі освіти
зверніть увагу як я вам вже казала що
заяви подані в паперовому вигляді мають
одразу статус зареєстровано закладі
освіти тобто вони не можуть бути
скасовані вступником з електронного
кабінету скасовано вступнику може бути
тільки заява зареєстрована в єдемо чи
потребує оточення
також
закладу освіти може встановити заяві
статус відмовлено тільки якщо вона
знаходиться в статусі або потребує
оточення вступником або рекомендовано
після того як вашому закладі якісь
відбулись ступні Випробування результати
До речі вступних випробувань є бо ви
нікуди не вносити це все відбувається в
закладі освіти ви можете встановити
заяві статус рекомендовано до з
урахуванням бюджету або зарекомендовано
до зарахування контракту після цього ви
одним натисканням Я зараз покажу як
можете створити картку здобувача
повертаємось до ідебо
дивимось у нас є бачите заяви вже є в
різних статусах і ось наприклад У нас є
заява зареєстрована в єдину Ми через
меню активні дії можемо змінити її
статус
зареєстровано в закладі освіти Тобто Це
була електронна заява подана з кабінету
вступника після цього як відбулись якісь
вступні випробування чи співбесіди ви
можете змінити статус заяви на
рекомендоване наприклад бюджет і після
цього ви можете
знову ж таки через меню активні дії
натиснути створити здобувача освіти
Зверніть будь ласка увагу ось тут у нас
з'явилась одразу код здобувача
Якщо у нас вступник подає паперову заяву
ви можете
через меню активні дії натиснути додати
іншу заяву вступника І у вас вже основні
дані щодо вступника будуть заповнювати
ви тільки заповнюєте інформацію щодо
конкурсної пропозиції
Ну і власне натискаєте потім
зареєструвати бачите у нас навіть
виділена вже пільгові категорії які
вступник вказав в попередній заяві
До речі щодо карток здобувачів може
створити одночасно кілька карток
здобувача ще Хочу звернути вашу увагу на
наступне коли ви встановлюєте заяві
електронні заяві статус
потребує уточнення в кабінеті вступника
така заява
отримує ось такий червоний заголовок
Тобто це має привернути увагу вступника
не те що потрібно там щось зробити він
заходить в заяву він може додати
коментар також він може наступні дії Він
після того як додав необхідний коментар
він натискає дані оточення також він
може скасувати Цю заяву або ну залишити
її без змін
власне в мене все наші питання
так
я так розумію переходимо до питань
відповідей правильно
пані Марина так
поїхали перша Олена Маленко
[оплески]
Скажіть будь ласка наразі ми
перетворення поки що заява розумієш поки
що ліцензії є Де ви не відображені чи
буде
в нас створювати конкурсну пропозицію
технічно створення конкурсних пропозицій
у нас не обмежена якимись датами
але просто маєте на увазі що вступник
має встигнути побачити ваші конкурсні
композиції в електронному кабінеті
вступника ну або діяти відповідно правил
прийому вашого закладу і Можливо там
просто будете приймати паперовому
вигляді це все залежить від того коли ви
їх створите
так Давайте тоді
пані Олена випускаєте мабуть руку та
пані Наталя з
Так секунду бо воно в мене скаче
пані Наталя будь ласка
вітаю ще раз а Підкажіть будь ласка в
мене така можливо можна показати
демонстрацію екрану щоб я нагляду
зробила зараз секунду так
дивіться в мене є така професія
наприклад кухар і
активна дія редагувати і вона в нас
Ми маємо на неї ліцензію але єдине що
внесення
по виду первинної професійної підготовки
відбувається не через моно професію Хоча
вона одна а я можу вибрати яка вона там
тільки лише в видах професійної
підготовки інтегрованих ліцензій ми
маємо одну професію
ліцензію на кухаря маємо ще також
відповідно ліцензію на кондитера а також
у нас іще є така професія кухар-кондитер
на базі дев'яти класів і їх ми можемо
обрати тобто ліцензія Вона одна на дві
професії тобто одразу інтегрована воно
показує мені в цьому ці колоночці
первинна професійна чи правильно я ще
роблю чи можливо я щось роблю
неправильно Чи можу я для вступників на
базі 11 класів вибирати первинну
професійну але уже з видо професійної
підготовки інтегровані ліцензії
А може ти показати кухаря зараз ліцензія
показати
секундочку
А так Господи де у нас тут
заклад освіти так ліцензії
за сферами освіти дивіться сейчас воно
підгрузиться от ліцензії ПТО Да у нас є
окрема ліцензія на кухаря І от в неї є
рівень освіти перший початковий і
вид професійної підготовки тут нічого
немає але стоїть види професійної
інтегрована є все і зараз секундочку
Дивіться ви в конкурсному пропозицію у
вас мають бути параметри ті самі що в
ліцензії тобто нічого страшного якщо
буде тут все Тому що я думаю що я
дивлюсь у нас є окремо кухар є окремо
кондитер тому що ми на них можемо робити
і підготовку перепідготовкою і так далі
А уже на базі дев'яти класів в нас
первинна професійна і знову ж таки
первинна професійна йде в інтегрованих
ліцензіях в конкурсній пропозиції має
відповідати ліцензії інакше вона нам
просто у вас не служиться тобто нічого Я
робила все правильно я так кажу як
правильно це дуже дякую
що при створенні картки здобувача
початок навчання в картці буде вказано
відповідно даних якій було вказані в
конкурсній пропозиції Ну правильно в нас
наприклад це сказав ставлено дата там
01.09 по
20.01.25 так само буде в створенні
картки здобувача
Зрозуміло дякую вам велике
так
давайте будь ласка
lcpто є в мене такий користувач
запитати таке дивіться
чого нас чутно дивіться є графа чи
підтверджена внесення конкурсної
пропозиції стоїть хрестик тобто
пропозиція внесенала ще м'яким чином
вона підтверджується це ви підтверджуєте
внесення вчителя Ні це ви підтверджуєте
внесення Тобто ви коли натиснули на цю
ознаку і натиснули зберегти Ця конкурсна
пропозиція вважається внесеною вона є
доступною для вибору в електронному
кабінеті вступника
з'являється пізніше
обираєте цю галочку встановлюєте цю
галочку натискаєте зберегти все воно
встановлено
рухаємось далі мабуть та
значить Сокальський професійний ліцей
Доброго дня Я вже спробувала створювати
конкурсну пропозицію але в мене ну я
заповнюю все згідно зразку в мене
вибиває помилку термін навчання не
відповідає діапазону між датою печатку
навчання та датою закінчення навчання
максимально допустима розбіжність має
становити не більше одного місяця хоча
дати початку навчання і закінчення
навчання це згідно навчальних планів Я
розумію Можливо ви період навчання
встановлюєте неуважно тобто повних років
і місяці їх будь ласка перевірте це три
роки нас навчання А там де термін
навчання місяців більше як 11 я
поставити не можу
чекайте на базі якої освіти
як більше 11 можна поставити 12 можна
писали в роз'яснення це
місяці ставиться максимально одинадцять
Все я вам чесно кажу якщо 12 ви додаєте
рік і там нуль стоїть
ви ж кажете що у вас термін навчання три
роки три роки три роки дивіться давайте
пані Марина Давайте я скажу навчання
може бути так два роки вісім місяців
один рік-два місяці
неправильно Я просто думала що треба три
роки перевезти ще місяць Так
потрібну кількість
поїхали далі бачу Сергія Олександровича
Добрий день
вітання вітання
[музика]
у вас працює шумадав десь Візьміть
мікрофончик ближче до себе або говоріть
прямо в нього не в сторону від нього
питання будь ласка там назву Чи краще
код є Де Бо називати щоб ми може
паралельно будемо дивитись щоб краще
підказувати 95
при внесенні конкурсної пропозиції полів
дата прийому заяв закінчення
правила прийому до закладів професійної
освіти відповідно в правилах прийому до
безпосередньо до закладу освіти Такі
дані не передбачені ми вносимо його
керуючись ситуацію да чи якимось окремим
нормативним документом
повторіть Пані Вікторія просить щоб ви
повторили запитання починаючи зі слів в
типових правилах прийому будь ласка
прийому відсутні такі поля як дата
початку подачі заяв і дата закінчення
відповідь коли ми на рівних області
затверджували в нашій правила прийоми
також ці поля не були ми їх зараз
визначаємо
якимось окремим нормативним документом
він передбачено
колеги Дивіться Ну власне специфіка
профтефа так як я ж сказала на початку
тобто в нас немає якогось базового
конкретного старту якогось конкретного
закінчення якщо у ваших правилах прийому
от як у ваших правилах прийому виписано
Так ви вносите
не буде якихось там додаткових чи
якогось іншого
часу початку і часу закінчення Від
міністерства освіти і науки ми просто
розуміємо що в нас має вся
фіналізуватися до початку навчального
року коли ми кажемо про первинну
професійну освіту а вже потім якщо у
випадку буде продовжено То ви просто
потім змінити цю дату завершення Ну якщо
ми якщо буде потреба продовженні там на
вересень місяць поки що Ми не розуміємо
Добре дякую
так Давайте тоді Ігор Доценко
Доброго дня колеги ліцей морського
транспорту код базі 1965 в мене декілька
питань перше питання
стосується такої технічної частини
наш адміністратор створював паперову
заявку на конкурсну пропозицію і
помилково вибрав не ту конкурсну
пропозицію там у нас є професія кухар є
отдельно кухар кухар судовий потрібно
було подати на кухар судновий А коли
просто на кухар Як тепер бути треба
створювати акт Чи це перше питання
Ні а помилки в діде бо вони створюєте ви
подаєте нову заяву вступника створюєте
відео або попередньої встановлювати
статус відхилення закладами
Я зрозумів Дякую друге питання
якщо ми виконуємо набір по одній
професії
декілька груп однак бюджетна одна
контрактна конкурсну пропозицію ми
прописуємо в одній там 30 бюджет 30
контракт Чи нам треба складати дві
конкурсні пропозиції одну на бюджетну на
контракт
можна створити дві Якщо ви хочете
розділити ці конкурси якщо ми хочемо
зробити в кінці дві різні групи ну одна
бюджетного Якщо ви будете робити дві
різні групи то ви власне їх краще одразу
поділіть тому що у вас є розуміння що
вам Спочатку треба заповнити групу
бюджетників а потім якщо у вас буде
дійсно більша кількість учнів і у вас В
правилах прийому відповідно виписано
конкурсний відбір тобто тим хто не
пройшли наприклад на бюджет ви будете
пропонувати контракт Або можливо хтось
одразу Хоче йти на платний якщо це
дорослі до приклади вони готові платити
то одразу робіть дві різні конкурсні
пропозиції якщо
вони не виключно на контракт то доцільно
просто однокорпусну пропозицію робити а
або так але тоді Ну там ліцензійний
обсяг вже дозволяє можете зробити одразу
спочатку такого а потім запропонувати
контракт там можна так проблем з при
створенні потім при зарахування їх на
навчання у проблем при створенні
додаткової групи у нас не виникне Чи
вони будуть зараховані в одну групу
не знаю 60 осіб 30 бюджетних і 30
контрактів
розумієте
в картці здобувачів визначте Зрозуміло
дякую Дякую за відповідь Дякую за
допомогу
так
Ярослав Тимошенко будь ласка ой стоп не
те нажав перескочило давайте Ярослава
все-таки секунду
Так в мене є питання
більшість заяв вступників які приходять
до нас на навчання подаються паперові
форми якщо не буде порушенням якщо майже
всі заяви вступників буде створювати
адміністратор ЄДР паперової заяви а не з
електронних кабінетів які створили
потенційні учні
це питання до вас чи до іншого ресурсу Я
не знаю дайте мені відповідь будь ласка
можна я скажу свою позицію
На сьогодні це просто сервіс Для
зручності показати можливо наприклад як
у вищий фахові передвищій освіті де
паперові заяви подають тільки ті які
пільговики тобто зараз у вас є варіанти
як завгодно робити
власне моя відповідь точно така сама Ви
працюєте з тим що є якщо до вас всі
вступники приходять
і приносять паперові заяви він просто
створюєте їм заяви у вас не буде не буде
не буде дублюючої роботи картка
здобувача формується Там просто галочкою
один кліком ну її не треба буде заново
заново перенабирати в інформацію вводити
один раз
електронний заяви в електронному вигляді
вони Для зручності здобувачів Для
зручності абітурієнтів які там ну там чи
не хочуть чи з безпекових причин не
можуть до вас там приїхати Чи вони там
тимчасово за кордоном чи ще Але вони
хочуть до вас вступити через те У них є
можливість подати Цю заяву через свій
створивши свій кабінет і ви її
зобов'язані розглянути точно так само як
вибори розглядали паперову
От і все А порушення ніякого не буде А
якщо так
так не ті за вас
значну це і вам зручніше чим якби чим
більше чим більше дітей через електронні
кабінети подастя тим менше вам руками
набирати про них інформацію
все одно то протягом літа ми можемо на
всіх створити картки фізичних осіб а не
робити це на початку вересня
заходимо Звісно що у мене є
претензія до адміністраторів ЄДР бо в
закладах тим що коли ви в попередні роки
працювали із картками здобувачів та
картки здобувачів створювались не
протягом трьох днів як написано в це в
типових правилах прийому і навіть і
навіть не протягом п'яти днів як
написано в положенні про єдебо А ви там
дозволяли собі їх створювати там півроку
а той довше і це Ну робить інформацію в
єд- в є Де Бо про здобувачів освіти
зовсім невалідною І от очевидно очевидно
що з цих причин
ми ну цей рік ще не сильно але в
наступні роки правила будуть трошечки
жорсткіші
доповню трошки
основний Стимул скоріше внесення карток
здобувачів був я так думаю
видача учнівських квитків А зараз
Звертаю увагу ще раз Що у вас вказано в
конкурсні пропозиції терміни подання
заяв тобто заява повинна бути внесено
Саме ці терміни
Давайте будемо рухатись далі пані Ілона
моя дивлюсь я думав що ми будемо
відповідати на запитання буде менше ти
бо ми ж на них відповідає Ми
відповідаємо на запитання їх на кожний
на кожну відповідь два нових
давайте пані Ілона будь ласка
Мені також вносити в базу Так у вас
повинен бути єди у вас в єдиному в блоці
заяви має бути єдиний Список заяв
поданих на дану конкурсну пропозицію ті
які діти подали через кабінети
так А в мене щось
зі звуком
Це ваш телефон Ілона Ну гаразд
власне
має бути єдиний перелік заяв
відповідно
підписав підписали ви наказ про
зарахування в цих заявах проставили
галочки сформувалися автоматично картки
здобувачів все
прошу будь ласка наступним Давайте тоді
Тетяна Омельчук будь ласка
[оплески]
Доброго дня Скажіть будь ласка ви кажете
вносите всі паперові заяви А якщо в нас
наприклад конкурс три абітурієнта на
місце то замість 30 здобулочин освіти
нам треба внести 90
це перше і друге секретар приймальної
комісії Він не є користувачем єдебло
тобто він не працює то це треба
адміністратору Виконувати обов'язки
секретаря
або проконсультувати своїх своїх
абітурієнтів щоб вони самі поносили свої
заяви через електронний кабінет або
додати ще користувачів ну власне бачите
опції не одна можете просто надати дітям
консультацію вони самі зроблять собі
кабінети самі все заповнять але в даному
випадку треба ще
зробити хто приймальній комісії щоб вони
були користувачем ви можете зробити це
не тільки на майбутнє зараз також
запущена приймальна компанія це вже так
робити
Ми протягом тижня
працюємо пакети з заявами на
користувачів будь ласка по-перше це не
відносно недовго по-друге наша з вами
вступна кампанія триватиме весь липень
весь серпень з великою долею ймовірності
весь Вересень і навіть можливо жовтень
Тобто ви маєте маєте можливість точно це
зробити
тобто заяви обов'язково паперові
переносині так можна ще раз попросити
щоб спочатку озвучували назву закладу
щоб ми могли
29,88 професійно-технічне училище
Рівненської атомної електричної станції
Так ми кола моторний будь ласка
зараз я
попрошу вас
Доброго дня вітаємо
Ну моє питання трошки поєднується з
попереднім але не почув для себе
відповіді Дивіться якщо на сьогоднішній
день у мене вже є 20 заяв паперових на
професію перукар до як ви кажете до
жовтня місяця їх може бути ще
30-40-50 як дітям відповідати які от
іменно не пройдуть конкурс це ж не
людське вони це нікуди вообще не
поступлять
перефразуйте запитання Що А як ви
відповіли А як ви відповідали в минулому
році тим дітям які не пройшли конкурс
році після того як ми на 15 серпня
сформували контингент ми проводили
зарахування по середньому балу в даному
випадку свідоцтво за дев'ять за 11
класів і казали в оці діти пройшли в
конкурс ще не прийшли конкурс вважаєте
ідіть на контракт ні забирається
документ але тоді у дітей є ще шанс
поступити в інші навчальні заклад
Дивіться я можу з позиції технічної
реалізації цього року дитина через
електронний кабінет свій власний так
який вона сама собі створить має право
подати одночасно п'ять заяв чи на різні
професії так до п'яти ну тобто немає
значення кількість закладів але 5 заяв
на п'ять різних конкурсних пропозицій
залишається у дитини можливість
поступити ще раз п'ять закладів кожен
заклад Може хоч по 10 подати Та ні я вас
просив щоб ви мені зробили їх всього
п'ять не більше добре я перепишу на
наступний рік я технічне завдання на
наступний рік перепишу це ж не інститут
люди добрі
пане Микола в чому В чому проблема
проблема дивіться я за тиждень до
початку навчання 1 вересня повинен дати
наказ про зарахування учнів так Ви зараз
кажете що до жовтня місяця буде
продовжено набір і я буду продовжувати і
далі заповнювати хто не набрав А у вас
буде виконана ваша програма мінімум і
все дивіться у вас конкурсна пропозиція
просто закриється вона Ну вона пропаде
із переліку тих яку дитина може вибрати
вона не не вибере її і буде чекати кінця
жовтня чи що там Поки ви її відмовите ну
не бачу проблем тобто якщо зараз ви мені
по конкурсної пропозиції 30 осіб на
регіональне замовлення 30 чоловік прийде
і конкурсна пропозиція закриється ну
залежить від того що у вас я ну я у вас
конкурс не макро якщо би без конкурсу
зараховуєте туда то ви виконали
регіональне замовлення і все
у нас конкурс був ну конкурс Був уже по
именно конкретно по свідоцтвом или Чи я
можу ограничити якимсь терміном не не
завершення
іменної
самої виборчої кампанії Добрий день А
коли це у вас конкурс конкурс уже
відбувся коли у наступна компанія
починається перша хвиля коли дитина
видали документи про ще не відбулося але
заявою
ви тільки що сказали По свідоцтвом
конкурс був я не був в прошлом у мене
запитали
як було в прошлому році добре у минулого
у минулому році Дивіться ви наказ
видається про зарахування то закладу про
в тих освіти свого ви даєте до першого
вересня і зараховуєте дітей і закриваєте
конкурсну пропозицію якщо у вас ліцензія
30 осіб ви набрали 30 осіб і все Я не
бачу ніяких проблем тому що у нас щороку
продовжується вступна кампанія або до 1
жовтня а під час війни і до 1 листопада
це означає
необов'язковість а можливість добрати
дітей до тих груп де є вільні місця у
вас є достатньо ліцензійний обсяг це не
обов'язковість це можливість
ми відповіли тому що це питання
на розгляд навчального закладу
коли виконали регіональне замовлення Так
коли набрали групу давайте Глухівський
агротехнічний будь ласка
Доброго дня мене чутно так
сервівський Микола Миколайович 6425 у
мене таке питання в інструкції написано
що конкурсні пропозиції робляться тільки
для
первинно-професійної підготовки так А
коли буде реалізована можливість робити
конкурсний пропозиції для
професійно-технічного навчання мається
на увазі від освітньої діяльності як
тільки знайдемо гроші на цю реалізацію
станом на сьогодні ми реалізуємо за той
бюджет який був реалізували можливість
яка дозволить охопити максимально
можливі максимально можливо кількість
якби потенційних учнів да максимально
можливо кількістю абітурієнтів якщо у
мене професійно-технічне навчання тільки
абітурієнтів то ви працюєте так як
працювали Минулого року правильно
це на увазі
правила користування
що отримують вашу випускники
кваліфікації тобто визов вносити дані
слухачів так
все дякую дякую Дуже вам дякую за
питання будь ласка пані Людмила будь
ласка
Добрий день Людмила кравці 2148
Підкажіть будь ласка Якщо ви обираємо
хочемо інтегрувати професію одна
професія в нас атестована наприклад
кухар друга професія не атестована вона
не підтягує нам ту другу професію яка не
атестована
конкурсний пропозицій
ліцензія горить помирання Та яка не
атестована
Справа в тому що немає забороняти будь
ласка зробіть звернення вкажіть ID ваших
ліцензій ми розглянемо окремо
ресурс так Все правильно
Все правильно ми розглянемо окремо вам
повідомлення
пані пан Олександр ападченко будь ласка
Доброго дня
1899 Це номер заклад у мене більш таке
життєве запитання Скажіть будь ласка
після створення картки зобовичів він
автоматично підтягується як він вже на
нас навчається правильно розумію так
спочатку яка була вказана в конкурсній
пропозиції будь ласка якщо б Наприклад
ми створили його якась трудового
навчання наприклад там ну в кінці серпня
а він нас наступний день пройшов сказав
щоб вибачаєте я хочу іншу професію ну
таке буває у нас там хотів бути кухарем
потім я придумав поспілкувався з
батьками хочу бути там сварщиком як нам
бути у такій ситуації
що Це вже неможливо таке що є така
конкурсна пропозиція і терміни подачі
заяв не завершились він А мені що
зробити з цим з робочим його відмінити
скасувати звільнити відрахувати
якщо наказ про зарахування бо то
відрахувати якщо помилку То скасовується
тобто Там буде така можливість що
скасувати там по якості картки здобувача
чи як це буде
всі Дивіться ви створюєте картку
здобувача Після того як я у вас виданий
наказ правильно не просто все правильно
У нас все правильно це особа вже як
здобувач відраховується відраховується
заново получається через конкретну
пропозицію правильно розумію так так
якщо на іншу професію цю професію
заява і таке інше все Я добре дякую
зрозумів
Він же може одразу кілька заяв подати
Тобто я зрозумів але ж знаєте буває таке
випадок що він Я хотів би тільки кухарем
а потім про що скажу хочу бути водія
якщо мені потім робити все я зрозумів
Дякую за відповідь
так будь ласка
Валентина Іванова
Доброго дня колеги в мене таке запитання
я створила конкурсні пропозиції і
намагалися створити заяву вступника ну
картку вступника і при пошуку конкурсної
пропозиції там мене не підтягнулись не
одної моєї конкурсної пропозиції чи це
буде з 1 липня чи щось я зробила не так
А які у вас дати прийому заяв стоять
ваші фонди 6 липня відповідно раніше ніж
1 липня вони її не знаходять Я просто
намагалась попробувати тому і думаю
надіялась що вони підтянуться всі щоб
можна було попробувати ну ще ж не
наступила 1 липня тому вони її
недоступні Для вибору Ну добре Дякую
тоді
друзі Дивіться маленькі технічне
зауваження
з наших попередніх мої пані Марини і
моїх колег тут директораті там телефоном
з вашими колегами найбільш часто
запитання це стосувалося там створення
конкурсних пропозицій на інтегровані
професії і відповідно для цього я
підготував спеціальну Google форму щодо
Ну там всі запитання які там не будуть
розглянуті чи які
не реалізовані програмному забезпеченні
щоб я міг одномоментно їх всі зібрати та
і з колегами із інфоресурсу
проговорювати на наступний технічне
завдання там на модерні модернізацію
програмного забезпечення але я дивлюсь
що ви отримаєте там поступово відповіді
на запитання і з трансляції від балів ти
стояв цей маленький анонс роблю Я вам
зараз посилання на цю Google форму Тобто
ми продовжимо відповіді на запитання але
загалом по роботі з єдебо цього року це
там різні просто є великий блок це там
неможливо створити конкурсну пропозицію
і плюс інші проблеми які у вас виникають
які щось не виходить я ставлю це
посилання зараз сюди в чати після нашого
вебінару я додам в опис трансляції на
Ютубі тобто воно ніде ніде не пропаде та
Google форма вона буде постійно
актуальна ви зможете навіть якщо зараз
не зберегли зможете знайти цю трансляцію
на Ютубі зайти в опис трансляції і там
от зараз умовно У вас нема питань чи
проблем та ви почали працювати щось
виникло щоб ви мали там
швидкі зворотний зв'язок там ну або
офіційне звернення якщо якщо ви точно
розумієте що це там
проблема ніде було пишете звернення
нефер ресурс от Якщо вам просто щось
незрозуміло то там ви ви якесь
повідомлення яке не розумієте чого воно
вам таке показуєте там ну по-перше би
текстом описуєте в чому проблема
по-друге можете
знімки екрану Та теж десь на хмарку
покласти і в те повідомлення вставити
посилання щоб нам було
зручні ну якби зручніше працювати над
вашими зверненнями де знайти посилання
на YouTube запис значить офіційний канал
мон в Ютубі трансляція там не за не не
плейлисти не відео а саме трансляція Це
буде десь третя кнопочка так і це там
вот зараз Після ну скільки йому треба
буде часу це перекодувати Але приблизно
через годину після вебінару воно вже там
буде І в описі до цього Ну по-перше буде
весь запис той то що за у нас з вами
зараз відбувається по других по-друге
буде посилання на цю Google форму от я
пропоную рухатись далі пані Надія
смоліна будь ласка
13.95 Ми не такі загальні питання але
дуже турбують Скажіть будь ласка скільки
заяв вступник може подати все ж таки Бо
не дуже зрозуміле
обмеження таке Давайте давайте я скажу 5
більше вам більше вам не треба цього
року
Якщо я вношу їх паперову заяву
і ви пропонуєте робити картку здобувача
Я тільки після того як буде
наказ про зарахування наказ про
зарахування я планую робити 25 серпня то
ця людина коли це було очна і людина
приносила саме мені свій піймав
документу я знала що більше він нікуди
не піде Ну може і піде але його там не
візьмуть зараз до 25 серпня І я
знаходжуся в подвішеному состоянії тобто
в мене він висить Я готова його прийняти
і ще 4 заклади готові його прийняти яким
чином Хто з нас його зарахує що хто
перший став того етапки тобто я першого
серпня я взяла робила наказ Я встигла
людина другого серпня вона вже не
встигла що Ось таке питання перше
Якщо коротко То так відповідь Так хто
перший встав того етапки
тобто розумніше Якщо я зробила йому або
сам вступник зробив електронний кабінет
і якщо я зробила або я зробила йому
паперовий заяву то я відразу зроблю йому
картку здобувача І в мене буде хоч якась
впевненість що він буде таким
почнемо з того що на підставі чого вступ
Микола зараховуйте
на підставі наказу в наказ він попадає
коли він приносить документів напевно ну
так він він 10 заповідник приносить а в
один заклад тобто забув це би з
оригіналі документів того Міністерства
буде відповідно виховувати А але якщо
людина знаходиться за кордоном і вступає
вона наразі мені не може надати оригінал
свого документа ніяк
Почекайте він не може подати
скажемо оригіналу сканкопії він
направляє в усі заклади на всяк випадок
Да він і мені надіслав і вам надіслав
іще трьом-чотирьох десяти кому хоче так
Ну це ж наші люди ми з цим стикалися в
нас єдине було це оригінал наразі зараз
ну майже 60 навіть більше відсотків
людини вони не можуть нам принести
оригінал Ну ще Нагадую що ми Харків
треба з міністерством обговорити як це
організаційно А я собі я собі записав ми
ну поки поки працюємо поки липень будемо
працювати власне із конкурсними
пропозиціями із поданням заяв то ваше
запитання буде відпрацьоване я собі
відмітив
Ні ти що є такі професії дуже популярні
наприклад перукар в нас і так є конкурс
і пільговий контингент дуже
користується тим що має конкурс у нас
проходить
Як у всіх на конкурсний бал атестату
пільговий контингент користується тим що
в них є пільги і скажіть мені будь ласка
в вищих учебних
є квота перша друга і там не більше
двох-трьох людей в групу може бути
зарахованим пільгового контенту ми
стикаємося з тим що в нас з 30-ти може
бути 20 людей пільгового контингенту Ви
розумієте ну це дуже складно для закладу
яким чином можна врегулювати це питання
Давайте так давайте так все на
сьогоднішній день типові правила не
передбачають жодних квот для пільгового
контингенту правильно
згідно правил ви повинні приймати
абсолютно всіх
значить щодо врегулювання знову ж таки я
запишу це ваше запитання пообіцяти
нічого не можу тому що Ну там Самі
розумієте
в закладі освіти то ми бачили тільки
заяв які нам подавалися Наприклад в мене
регіональне замовлення на якусь професію
було 30 людей якщо в мене приходила 60
заяв то я вже ставила помітку і на сайті
викладала що набір в цю групу закрита і
проводила конкурс серед цих 60 осіб які
в мені Наприклад станом на 5 липня але
вони в мене вже є я можу проводити
конкурс повинен мене і так вже дві
людини на одне місце Зараз в конкурсній
пропозиціях я не можу спрогнозувати яким
чином будуть заноситися ці заяви скільки
людей буде І якщо в конкурсних
пропозиціях я буду вносити дату
наприклад з 1 липня до 25 серпня я могу
стикнутися з тим що на одну на моїй 26
ліцензований обсяг можуть подати порядка
ста- заяв з яких
мені дуже важко по-перше буде проводити
конкурс по-друге пільговий контингент ну
це дуже такий бо вони обривають телефон
зараз і особливе питання
щодо військовослужбовців вони не зовсім
правильно розуміють оце пільгу що якщо
Вони служать то їх діти мають право
першочергового зарахування ми їм
пояснюємо що є тільки якщо загин вони
являються дітям дітьми які у якого в
яких батьки загинуло але з військовими
дуже важко
спілкуватися
закон пишете немино є таке
і
тобто якщо я в конкурсних пропозиціях
занесла термін з 1 липня по 25 серпня
Але я бачу що момент першого серпня в
мене вже 60 заяв на 30 місць ці мо- чи
можу я скоригувати і якось ну дати
розуміти що я закрила прийом на цю
професію як мені зупинити цей Шквал заяв
бо я не не впораюся з цими в мене будуть
дуже багато нарікань батьки учні
яким чином закрити якщо я бачу що в мене
жах
зараз про правила секунду будь ласка
бо там тільки додатковий можна дати
коригувати А якщо я вже поставила і
отримала хоч одну заяву вже я нічого не
можу змінити
що робити
Я бачу що всі кивають але нічого
відповіді
Дайте Секунду зараз
тому що фахова дати вам відповідь на це
запитання це я не можу на жаль
У вас У вас ще запитання є там ми можемо
це запитання ще одне
одне подала заяву
така вона вже не літня але їй 30 років
Вона закінчила 8 класів після цього
працювала ніде ніяку кваліфіковану
кваліфікацію не отримувала і вона хоче
навчатися в групи 9 класу подала заяву
чи може я її прийняти вона ніде освіту
не отримувала ніяких записів в трудовій
в неї що їй присвоєна якась кваліфікація
в неї немає чи може я тридцятирічну
людину посадити в групу 9-го класу
і повна загальна середня освіта і
відповідно професія теоретично можна
якщо ми є документи про базову загальну
в законі ніде не сказано і немає
обмеження обмеження вікового немає
теоретичної теоретично можна
бо Я намагалася їй пояснити що їй
потрібно піти у вечірню школу отримати п
ЗСУ на що вона мені не було Це було б
краще звичайно це було б краще але тоді
б вам треба тоді вам треба створювати
групу а можливо вона у вас є Без ну
здобуття професії без здобуття повної
загальної середньої освіти це термін це
навчальний план зовсім інший термін
інший і в принципі тоді вони можуть
Навчатися або в вечірній школі або в
іншому закладі або взагалі експертном
здобувати це у нас не заборонено
здобувати повну загальну середню освіту
і на кінець того як вона навчиться і
буде отримувати у вас По ідеї диплом
кваліфікованого робітника вона мала би
вам принести уже
свідоцтво про повну загальну середню
освіту здобуття але оці свідоцтво про
закінчення повної загальної середньої
освіти якщо її прийму на навчання без
надання повна загальна середня освіта
просто буду навчати професію Чи
обов'язково вона мені на кінець повинна
надати довідку що в неї є ця пзо
зміни обов'язково ми ж внесли зміни і
дозволили здобуття професії без здобуття
повної загальної середньої освіти коли
треба дивитися
але що є стандарти є професійною
освітній стандарт у професійному
освітньому стандарті є є на вході
коли іде на навчання у нас здобуваючи
освіти Ну вступник і є на виході як
правило тобто інколи у професіях
написано що треба мати на виході при
працевлаштуванні та випускник має мати
повну загальну середню освіту уважно
Уважно Дивіться якщо є такі вимоги якщо
не в освітньому то в професійному
професійному або колібрі характеристиці
ну це є відслідковуйте щоб так все я
зрозуміла де це прослідкувати дякую пані
Надія будь ласка попереднє ваше
запитання про цей попередньо В мене
запитання було таким конкурсні
пропозиції Я не можу спрогнозувати
кількість заяв тому я ставлю що і заяви
я буду приймати з 1 липня по 25 серпня
Але на момент 1 серпня на свої 26
ліцензованих як місць я могу отримати
таку ситуацію з якою я вже декілька
разів стикалася в попередніх роках що в
мене буде на 26 вже 60 заяв Коли це було
очна я просто казала людям коли
приходили до мене приймальну комісію я
казала Все набір закінчено ми будемо
працювати з тими 60 заявами які є і все
тут не можна змінити термін якщо 1
серпня я побачив що в мене дуже велика
кількість заяв Я знаю що не можна
змінити термін я не можу закрити Цю
конкурсну пропозицію а опрацювати потім
ще 60
Зрозуміло у нас по законодавстві ніде не
визначено що ви маєте Як у вищої освіти
або фахове передвищує що у нас конкурс
або вступна кампанія триває з і до у нас
компанія триває до 1 вересня тобто до 25
серпня те що вам треба буде багато
особливо опрацьовувати заяв дуже добре
що до вас так гарно йдуть йдуть
абітурієнти що значить ви користуєтесь
попитом але відмовити у прийманні заяви
коли у нас вступна компанія іде до 1
вересня я буду там ви ставите до 25
серпня це не є правильно ви повинні
прийняти заяву у обіторієнта і просто
тоді Зараз ми просили воєнний стан
зробіть зробіть конкурс свідоцтв чи
співбесіду не робіть ніяких екзаменів по
поспілкуйтеся але не прийняти заяву ви
не маєте право так але я стикаюся з
проблемою перше велика кількість
пільговиків перша проблема і Друга
проблема діти до 1 вересня які подали
заяву до мене Вони досі до 1 вересня не
будуть знати чи вони поступили і вони
втрачають свій час шанс поступити до
іншого навчального закладу коли я 1
серпня закриваю
е це питанням проведення конкурсу і 60
наприклад заяв я буду опрацьовувати то
ті 60 там 40 людей яких я відсила то
вони мають ще місяць для того щоб
поступити туди куди вони хочуть
я і ще раз відповідаю і ще раз по
законодавству і ще раз відповідаю ви не
маєте права до кінця вашої вступної
кампанії відмовити у прийманні заяви
далі учень І чи вступник по
правилам ну правилам типовим правилам
вступу має право подати до 5 закладів
тобто вони зразу обирають 5 закладів і
Вони вступають коли вони до вас
приносять ви їм кажіть якщо ви і ось
така у нас ситуація тому ви можете в
принципі іще подати до такого закладу і
порекомендувати який за такою ж професії
і тоді якщо ви йому не треба йому Місяць
коли ви зателефону і сказали що ось ми
провели у нас пільгові категорії тим
більше відмовити пільговим категоріям ви
не маєте права у нас є пільгові
категорії у вас там ми ну співбесіду
провели І тому ми рекомендуємо оскільки
ви подали ще в чотири будь ласка в нього
є день і він там три дні 5 днів у нього
є як я можу йому сказати що він подав 4
я ж не знаю куди він подав може він
подав тільки до мене Ми вступаємо уже в
дискусію Ми вступаємо уже в дискусію
права відмовити у вас немає Я вам і ще
раз як працівник Міністерства говорю Що
ви робите на місцях це вже інша ваша
справа права відмовити немає працюйте
комісія вступна комісія приймальна
комісія працює із абітурієнтами і
розказує спілкується скільки вони можуть
подати ви розказуєте їм ваше їхнє право
абсолютно все а як він вчинив і це далі
вже ну
Ми не можемо відповідати за кожного
Зрозуміло дякую будь ласка так давайте
дивитись далі
пані не знаю На жаль написано має ДНЗ
лвп у будь ласка
вам має запит прийти на ось Добрий день
скажіть будь ласка таке питання чи
наскільки ми розуміємо Наприклад якщо є
популярна професія припустимо перукар і
менш популярна припустимо там Кравець
на перукаря можуть подати заяви Ну уявну
там 60 чоловік а можемо взяти тільки 30
яким шляхом ми можемо запропонувати
дітям тільки вже подали ті заяви
електронні
перегітувати і я навіть не знаю на іншу
професію на менш популярну то ми їх
можемо усно переконати але технічно як
воно повинно відбуватися
що вступник може подавати заяви хоч на
всі конкурсні пропозиції і фактично
закладу освіти як ви його при цьому
будете переконувати це поза єдину
Ви повинні мати можливість цей ну
давайте ще раз де там мікрофончик Я
розумію але теоретично виглядає це
наступним чином якщо буде наприклад не
пропонуємо дитині тут Давай переконуємо
вам будеш кравцем він згідний стати
крацем Ми повинні щось зробити Ми
повинні його
анулювати заяву створити нову і буде
можливість технічна Наприклад якщо ми
бачимо що дитина
що він може сама політично змінити
наприклад на іншу професію
автоматично зміни
ти нему заяву він не може він може
подати заяву на іншу конкурсну
пропозицію і подавати заяву він може в
період вказаний вами в конкурсних
пропозиціях тобто наступним чином
31 числа проходить співбесіда 31 серпня
є тільки після 30 серпня ми можемо
запропонувати наприклад тому перукарію
який не пройшов попробувати на іншу
професію Чи як воно має виглядати ні
дивіться як я бачу з практичної точки
зору що
крайній терміни проведення та співбесід
та Чи випробують ви не можете не ставите
щоб був ще час коли особа не пройшла по
конкурсу в неї ще час подати наступну
заяву якщо ви нападала до вашого закладу
заяву то в принципі вона може до вашого
закладу ще інші заяви Подавати не
обмежено
так Але якщо ми розглядаємо до 31 числа
25 не ставте 31-го поставте 25
Якщо прийом конкурс відбір може
відбуватись поетапно ви ж не чекайте і
всіх починаєте
співбесіду проводити 31 числа близько
першого серпня когось 10 серпня І вже
знаєте набагато раніше що у вас чи
закінчилося місця чи не закінчилися
Але ми не можемо відмовити Це знов
повертаємося до першого до першого
запитання якщо 1 серпня закінчилось
місця а прийшли 2 серпня прийшли з
пільговим категорії Вони мають взяти
заяви все ми не можемо у нас не обмежена
у наступних за
рахувати
але якщо накази про зарахування вже є
тоді
накази будуть перед першим вересня не
маю у нас 1 серпня вони не роблять про
зарахування тому що вступна кампанія
триває до початку вересня Ну визначимося
там 24 Ну там 23 серпня Ну не до 1
вересня крім словом треба було питання
не сиді яке значення до кінця вересня
Вони реально не визначені до початку
вересня де вони є ми не визначені в
групах з якими групами скільки нам дітей
які контингент з яким балу
так далі я хочу тоді почути як тоді
трактуються пункт 4:2 типових правилах
що конкурсний відбір може проводитись
поетапно протягом усього періоду прийому
документів що це означає тоді
це наші всі пишу 31 серпня повинні
зарахувати тільки
це як це
унормуємо це питання Ну ми бачимо в
цьому потребу І звісно що розглянемо
нормуємо це питання
Давай давайте давайте будемо рухатись
далі бо ще два це ми вже ми вже і так
цей час 45
Давайте будь ласка пані Зоя Зараз я вам
до дозволю Ось будь ласка
Доброго дня всім Київське Київський
професійний коледж технологій та дизайну
одягу питання наступне в правилах
прийому немає пункту щодо зарахування
поза конкурсу внутрішньо переміщених
осіб Чи можемо ми внести зміни ну тобто
самостійно до власних правил що поза
конкурсом зараховується внутрішньо
переміщені особи це перше питання і
друге питання просто
Пані Вікторія
якщо в типових правилах прийому
немає то ви
не можете бо вони
типу можете на рівні але на рівні на
рівні свого закладу ви можете виписувати
і встановлювати тим більше якщо до
прикладу у вас конкурсу ну невеликий
конкурс скажемо так небагато заяв подано
то внутрішньо переміщення особи є в
пріоритеті в пріоритеті
пані Зоя Давайте без якщо можна трошечки
швидше друге ваше питання будь ласка
тепер питання також стосується
внутрішньо переміщених осіб але
приходять діти з довідкою про внутрішньо
перемічну особу наприклад з міста
Харкова Чи являється місто Харків
тим містом звідки можуть перенестися
внутрі ну тобто особи можуть
переміститися або наприклад з
довідка повинна мати якісь термін
Наприклад в мене є сьогодні прийшли до
приймальної комісії з Полтавської
області з довідкою внутрішньо-перенічної
особи давайте дивіться пані Зоя е-е
напишіть звернення на ну це точно не про
ЄДР бо запитання та не стосується нашого
вебінара Напишіть будь ласка навіть
просто на електронну пошту директорату
от ми розглянемо тому що Ну от Дивіться
ви спочатку питаєте Чи можемо ми
встановити правила і брати їх без
конкурсу випро ну тобто ви Тобто такого
ніби як нема а друге ви запитуєте
А якої форми повинна бути у них довідка
якщо ми їм це ну якщо ми таке правило
придумаємо
розумієте про що мова тобто з вами треба
окремо попрацювати давайте не будемо
загальний час на це витрачати
залишаються відкритим Добре дякую але
напишіть на електронну пошту з вами
зв'яжемо систему
якщо мене цікавить з приводу ВПУ
діти які
дуже вас
у нас буде такою як в минулому році що
діти які з реально тимчасово окупованих
територій закінчують в цьому році 9 або
11-й клас і вони
технічно відрахування може бути в
минулому році у мене особисто на це
витратилося майже два місяці
тобто дітей не могли відрахувати
технічну закладів освіти які знаходяться
на окупованій території
Вони висіли в тих закладах тобто вони не
були відраховані я не могла їх перевести
з курсу на курс або навіть прийняти
Чи якось буде в цьому році врегульована
це питання
Давайте давайте
ще раз питання про нормативку чи питання
про механіку роботи в базі ЄДР Про що ви
запитуєте
просить щоб ви її зателефонували і вона
з вами з цього приводу поспілкується
добре
Все давайте рухатись далі дптнз чпмл
віддавав взагалі почати
так Доброго дня вам місто Чернівці
машинобудівний ліцей
1960 номерів в мене таке питання бо не
могли б нести конкурсні пропозиції це
слюсар з ремонту колісних транспортних
засобів і водій категорії ВС взагалі
якщо я вношу я в місці дві пропозиції
галочки не поставити тому що Ці дві
професії не можу їх інтегрувати Вони
якби окремо я якби вже звертався він по
ресурс Вони сказали що це питання ще
розглядають от навіть сьогодні хочу я це
внести Ну не підтягуються навіть проста
професія ну мається на інші підтягуються
а от шлюцер до водія
не підтягуються перше питання будь ласка
Друзі на один рівень чи на різні вони
якби на одному якщо не помиляюся мали
бути на одному Які ще раз Скажіть які
шлюсари з ремонту автомобілів
і водій категорії BC Там трошки в нас Я
не знаю чому воно так воно було щоб
водій два рази писало водій і категорія
BC є навіть окремо водій у нас категорія
це навіть і він не підтягується так
просто для проби хотів оглянути але воно
тоже не підтягується
транспортних засобів Так вона одна
інтегрована або на професію вони не
поєднані в одній КП
От їх можна об'єднати так
одна ліцензія на інтеграцію одна
ліцензія нам можна професія приєднати
водні конкурсні пропозиції на сьогодні
неможливо новини ні одна Ні друга не
інтегровані тому що категорії тільки
чому дві категорії вважаються як
інтегрована в цьому плані типу водій б
водій це інтеграція
це питання треба розглянути
id-лицей
Напишіть будь ласка звернення на
технічного адміністратора і вкажіть як
діє ліцензії які ви намага Тобто це
питання Скоріш до відображення в
ліцензії
обговоримо і друге питання бо там було
навчання щодо 11 класів нашого два роки
Ну я знаю що про
491 постанови там було 24 тижні якщо це
півтора року що змінилося Чи ми можемо
дійсно там півтора Ну до двох ну це не
буде 2 роки це буде рік і 8 місяців ми
не дотримуємося деякі і шість місяців Да
початкова
на більше двох років
менше можна бо я кажу попередні нормати
вні на другий рік навчання на більше 24
тижнів А це виходить
два роки це 24 місяці
Так а там було 24 тижні на другому році
на навчання якщо рік
так що можна інтегрувати Якщо є
можливість
давайте цей момент я теж прослідку
прослідкую бо ми
може лікаря як називався той документ
який ми посилали з колекції граничні
норми
встановлювали
освіту да правильно от А ви А ви на це
ви на який про якісь інші документи
говорите можливо можливо
я можливо я його просто пропустив напиши
напишіть сюди мені чати про які
документи і я побіг і ще я хотів просто
уточнити у нас виходить ми співбесіду
завчасно зробили 27 приблизно липня такі
групи які завжди якби наділить що буде
конкурсні пропозиції виходить будуть Я
вже змінюю бо я постав до 31 серпня
зміни точно до 24 до 25-го але якщо ну
візьмемо самий такий кращий варіант щоб
ми на 27 число буде мати 60 здобувачів
освіти все ми умовно закриваємо ми
більше не маємо можливості набирати в
оригінальне замовлення не дає а умовно
тоже підійдуть до нас навіть ті самі ВПО
або джерути і так далі Чи можу я закрити
умовно да
наказ буде 28 червня
бо тому чому ми так рано робимо для того
щоб діти мали дійсно можливість щоб
кудись вступити Якщо не будуть мати
можливо чи в майбутньому
Давайте давайте знову ж таки щоб не
затягувати час я бачу я бачу що це
питання не цікавить не лише вас а й
інших колег там я я думаю Я думаю що це
колеги підготують офіційну роз'яснення
директорату от і ми тобто вивчать
детально детально і це розішлемо вам щоб
це було єдине централізована позиція від
директорату що до того як з цим
працювати добре
давайте рухатись далі пані Наталія
Антонюк по можливості Колеги давайте Ну
от конкретно бо Ми тримаємо її колекцію
інфоресурсу
трошить трошечки це точковіше питання
задайте
56 Ковельський центр втехосвіти мене
питання
інфоресурсу скажіть при внесенні
конкурсної пропозиції там де стоїть дата
оголошення першого списку рекомендованих
на загальних умовах я ставлю дату яка
іде згідно графіку співбесід по правилах
прийому
на кожного визначену професію
коли ви рекомендуєте в правилах
ми приймаємо заяви до 17 числа і перша
співбесіда в нас відбувається на
професію визначену наприклад Токар 18
значить в мене дата оголошення першого
списку буде 18-го так а дата зарахування
вже буде 30 серпня
Тобто це не раніше ніж 18 ви можете
рекомендувати добре ще таке по обсягу на
бюджет нас зазвичай після 25 серпня
відбувається коригування регіонального
замовлення нам по можливості якщо
наприклад стоїть конкурсна пропозиція 25
дають коригування і може бути 30 на
визначену професію як мені це здійснити
вже після 25 серпня
давайте це Олексій також зафіксує і ми
обговоримо
гаразд
якщо наприклад протягом подачі терміну
подачі заяви
абітурієнт підходить наприклад він пише
заяву 10 липня на одну професію а далі
передумує і пише заяву наприклад 10
серпня на іншу професію як мені це
здійснити і змінити конкурсну пропозицію
змінити конкурсну пропозицію якщо у вас
ще триває можливість подачі заяви особа
може подати кілька заяв це не обмежено А
куди вона
продезатами випробуваючи співбесід І
куди вона визначити подати оригінали
документів ви вже з нею вирізати Тобто
ви тільки однієї заяви і поставити
наприклад рекомендовано бюджети і тільки
по одній такій заяві створювати потім
парку здобувача добре Дякуємо все
зрозуміло
Так давай Давайте будь ласка
ВПУ сфери послуг
Добрий день
Тернопільське училище сфери послуг та
туризму код навчального закладу
24-69 Ми не можемо створити конкурсну
пропозицію у зв'язку з тим що на базі
повної загальної середньої освіти термін
навчання 2 роки а в нас згідно
навчального плану професія Кравець
закрійник термін навчання два з
половиною роки як поступити в такій
ситуації як створити таку конкурсну
пропозицію
Олексій
ми зараз було відповідно до положення
просто понивого світу півтора роки на
основі позасував вказано Міністерство
прийняло рішення до двох років збільшити
зараз вже дві з половиною
правовий акт власне положення
проступеневу освіту яке які які визначає
граничні строки строки навчання
тому
конкретно моя відповідь от моя Да на
базі тих документів з якими я знайомий
ніяк Тобто ви ви не можете цього зробити
це порушення Але знову ж таки пиши
пишіть пишіть звернення до директорату
коли колеги подивляться конкретно там
які Ну там Які у вас ліцензії які
навчальні плани і так і так далі за це
за цими професіями і нададуть вам
офіційну відповідь
дякую
[оплески]
давайте рухатись далі п Віктор Кушнір
не чути ви не включили мікрофон пане
Віктора
в нас є ліцензія на потрійну інтеграцію
яку поросян Бармен на базі 11 класів
термін навчання півтора року є в нас
можливість тільки кухарця як нам
сформувати конкурсну пропозицію на Ці
дві складові
якщо правильно зрозуміла ваше питання
тобто Ви маєте ліцензію на три професії
конкурсна пропозицію хочете створити на
дві з них
технічно це неможливо станом на сьогодні
технічно це неможливо
Заповніть Google формулу в чаті для того
щоб ми включили ваше питання ми
працювали і щоб мали контакт з вами якщо
доведеться щось уточнити це стосується
всіх колеги розінтеграція та добавляти
на базі інтегрованої інтегрованої
ліцензії зробити конкурсну пропозицію на
моно професію на базі двох інтегрованих
ліцензій з кожної вибрати по професії
там ще якусь там комбінувати конкурсну
пропозицію от всі всі питання що
стосуються неможливості створити ту чи
іншу конкурсну пропозицію будь ласка щоб
я весь їх спектр міг зафіксувати щоб я
міг з вами контактувати оце найголовні
зараз що мені потрібно в тій Google
формі про яку я говорив ще є у вас
питання Віктора А якщо ми при наявності
терміни проходження до двох років
добавляємо бармен це нас право за нами
залишається з півтора року на базі 11
класів до двох років щоб зняти проблему
як якщо ви Якщо ви вкладаєте вкладаєтесь
в терміни навчання то так два роки
ваша при введені в кабінеті
ліцензії при створенні конкурсної
пропозиції програм програма в
автоматично підхопить всі три професії
так і друге питання конкурсні пропозиції
на професії які
професійно-технічне чи курсового
навчання підвищення кваліфікації
завершення терміну ми яким чином тоді
формуємо групи
слухачів не здобувачів зараз слухачів
конкурсних пропозицій
коли колеги ще раз наголошую це про що
ми сьогодні говоримо стосується лише
первинної професійної освіти
підвищення кваліфікації
професійно-технічне навчання і інші види
підготовки Ви працюєте так як працювали
Минулого року будь ласка Так у вас інші
питання пані Наталя коротке коротка
ремарку до попереднього питання щодо
інтеграції на сьогодні
штучної інтеграцію можна зробити тільки
з ліцензій на моно професій тобто
об'єднати дві інтегровані одну
інтегровано одну моно неможливо тільки
за монопрофесією ну це в роз'ясненнях
також є так да в інструкції це детально
описано є три способи створити конкурсну
пропозицію і це конкурсна пропозиція на
моно професію з моноліцензії конкурсна
пропозиція за всіма професіями які
вказує вказані він в інтегровані
ліцензії і
інтегрована конкурсна пропозиція з
моноліцензії те про що щойно сказала
пані Марина три способи якщо ваш варіант
комбінування не попадає в один із цих
способів ви заповнюєте Google форму для
того щоб я міг ваш випадок розібрати
давайте
з пані Наталією поговоримо
Так в мене ще одне запитання навчальний
заклад 25-13 по-перше чи потрібно з бази
вивантажувати
заяви вступників і роздруковувати їх для
того щоб вкласти в особові справи
таке можливо просте запитання але
технічно така можливість є можливість є
Я маю на увазі чи вона обов'язково
Костянтина Добре
я не знаю
ну напевне в особовій справі повинні
бути в якомусь вигляді заяви тому
зрозуміло тобто якщо дитина до нас
приходить після заяву в паперовому
вигляді я її кладу в особову справу якщо
подавалася заява в електронному вигляді
я її вивантажую також кладу в особову
справу Я правильно розумію це логічно
зрозуміло це це Іще таке запитання
можливо не на часі але Підкажіть будь
ласка який зараз є алгоритм отримання
другої професійної освіти якщо людина
мала вищу освіту А хоче отримати
первинну професійну
якусь чи має вона таку можливість чи
тільки
свої гроші не за бюджетні контракт
зрозуміло тобто на за бюджет вона не має
можливості тільки контрактна основа це
дякую та бюджет Вона має право
відповідно до внесених змін рік назад до
закону Про професійно-технічну освіту в
п'яту статтю внесені зміни рік назад і
особа якщо вона має три роки стажу два
роки страхового стажу Вона має право
безкоштовно за гроші регіонального або
державного бюджету здобути
тобто навчатися за програмою
професійно-технічного навчання
підвищення кваліфікації це Чи
перепідготовка це стаття 5 закону
профтехосвіту І статті 50 в цього ж
закону там теж зміни і там якраз вказано
право фінансування бо це фіна- фінансова
частина у закону Ні не первинна але тому
що мене дуже часто люди займають ні але
це може бути професійно-технічне
навчання за
регіонального замовлення а якщо пер
винна професійна то тільки на контракті
правильно Так дякую
Так давай те
ВП овпту Оце те що я довго читать будемо
Доброго дня мене така запитання код
37.55 у нас нема функціоналу можливості
створення конкурсної пропозицій Тобто
нема графи конкурсна пропозиція ПТО а
також вступники ой заяви вступників ПТО
добре
можна так дуже дуже вам дякую і можна
буде створювати все Бо ми чекали Дуже
дякую вам гарного дня
так Олег
пан Олег вище з нами чи чи вже ні
добре Давайте тоді їхали їхали їдемо
далі березнівське ВПУ
Доброго дня наступне запитання код
заклад 94-3 Чи обов'язково вносити всі
паперові заяви в той же день коли вони
подаються вступникам чи можливо там
якось загружати їх Ну скажімо так
порціями наприклад раз в тиждень всі
я блін щоб вони вносились от прямо це
поки вступник біля вас щоб він бачив що
його заява внесена
ну це не обов'язково просто типу ми вас
ну якби зобов'язуючих документів нема
але
не публічний час робочий тоді можна це
вносити також щоб два різні варіанти це
вже самі налаштовуєтесь тобто якщо там
буде наприклад
страшного
дякую
Так давай
Світлана Калиниченко будь ласка
Вітаю Криворізький професійний
транспортно-металургійний ліцей
код 22-22 Скажіть будь ласка не можемо
створити пропозицію конкурсну пропозицію
на інтегровану професію слюсар з ремонту
колісних транспортних засобів
електрогазуварний тому що там я так
думаю що одну рівень освіти різний на
слюсаря получається третій вищий рівень
А на електрогазозварника іде другий
базовий рівень і вони не підтягуються
один до одного якщо ви бачили
роз'яснення Так там є скрін що з різним
рівнем воно не об'єднується в одну
конкурсну пропозицію що робити почекати
наступного оновлення є де бо думаю цей
давайте почекаємо спочатку рішення мон а
потім будемо казати про оновлення
з колегами проговорювали це питання
здавай Давайте тоді так щоб до Три Всі
дотримувалися однієї процедури тоді
опиши опишіть теж в Google формі свою
проблему от ми про неї знаємо вона
відома ми просто вас зафіксуємо окремо
добре
чекайте
[оплески]
це я можливо
так трапилось Що я комусь це в особисті
відправив хоча це мабуть
вже є
я це вже я третій раз Просто вставляю це
посилання сюди
Добре я буду спати посиланням
так о я забув на жаль як звуть вас Ви
писали Galaxy
людина писала в чаті Я забув просто
Якщо вам вдасться включити мікрофон То
можете говорити я дозвіл
з телефонами мабуть є якісь проблеми
давай Давайте тоді Ну комунікувати я там
розумію Я бачив Ірина вам відписала на
ваше запитання Давайте будемо
комунікувати напряму
поїхали далі нплб
Добрий день Вітаю
18-27 на даний час наш навчальний заклад
перебуває статусі припинення фізичної
особи прошу сказати вступну кампанію
припинення фізичної особи
та як
юридичної особи
одну компанію маємо проводити мир чи вже
навчальний заклад правонаступник
потім
якщо заклад стадії припинення вступну
кампанію проводять вони чи за чи той хто
наступне
вже реорганізація Ні не завершена Я
думаю що ви можете домовитися із тими і
закладом який буде правонаступником і ви
можете в принципі свої будівлі теж Ну як
буде як відділення
цієї частина
конкурс приймальної комісії Ви точно так
можете приймати ціле між собою
домовляйтеся якщо реорганізація не
закінчилася то ну ще ж немає окремої
ліцензії немає
перереєстрації закладу це вже ваші
внутрішні домовлятись
ліцензійні обсяги в якому в новому
закладі про наступнику цього закладу є
чи немає
як вони тоді домовляться коли обсяги в
Старому закладі і немає ніяких зв'язків
що це буде правонаступником
створюють створюють тоді два
дві конкурсні тоді пропозиції якщо ще не
закінчилось і немає ліцензії не передали
тим більше ліцензію будуть
переоформлювати по Тім по спрощеній теж
ви знаєте процедурі тому що зміни
внесені до закону до 19 статті А зараз
візується і буде видано зміни до
постанови про ліцензування провадження
освітньої діяльності тому в принципі
тоді дві можна тоді ще коментар сюди в
такому випадку якщо нема
технічного зв'язку взагалі що ліцензійні
обсяги будуть передаватись що
користуються правонаступник ліцензіями
реорганізовано тоді має сенси
зараховувати
в Старому закладі а потім вже
відрахування зв'язку з реорганізацією і
да да да да я так я думаю так тому що Ну
ця стадія реорганізації У нас є приклади
в стадії реорганізації можуть бути рік і
два Ну не дай Бог щоб такого було і все
але різні випадки був буває там про
передачу майна і все інше тому так А
якщо вже наші працівники отримали
повідомлення за два місяці про можливий
вивільнення Ну так і що Ну це ж
працівники отримали вони зв'язуйте зараз
працівників це процедуру це Кодекс
законів про працю так мали коли
видається наказ працівники повинні бути
повідомлення але це не значить що через
два місяці вони обов'язково будуть
звільнення це не не раніше ніж через два
місяці тобто раніше звільнити не можна а
пізніше можна А пізніше можна зрозуміло
добре Дякуємо зрозуміло Гарного дня
Так і вам Дякуємо
ставропігійський ВПУ
х
створюємо
тут там шумно Все будь ласка Ми вас
слухаємо
у вас не працює мікрофон
Я думаю це вот прямо мікрофон не працює
Тому що він включений але ми вас не
чуємо
ні ні це не або не той мікрофон в
системі вибраний і так далі
цей пишіть пишіть в чат я у мене був у
мене буде ще відповідь з приводу чатів я
Ну ми не проігноруємо і ці запитання от
але давайте спочатку з тими хто є наживо
добре
Так пані Віта будь ласка
Ой нарешті включився ваш мікрофон
місто Львів
питання наступне якщо людський фактор
випадково не внесли якусь заяву ми ту
дитину Потім можемо зарахувати
якщо людський фактор і не внесли заяву
ви потім ви потім
якщо ви не внесли їх в наказ про
зарахування Куди не внесли
е-е не внесли е-е в єдрбо заяву єдрбо ви
можете пізніше внести заяву і на базі на
базі заяву пізніше термінів визначених в
конкурсній пропозиції не можна а про
такі людські фактори Потрібно також
міністерством це питання
організаційно узгодити як це коли
напрацювати
для вищої освіти створюється звернення
про створення картки здобувача і так
далі Тобто Ну а тут ще скажем Віктор я
мав Я мав на увазі в ме- ну в межах цей
в межах набору тобто ну умовно це
Наприклад в вересні А ні ну ви ні
наприклад у вересні не знаю давай це як
Віктор каже в- окремим цим
питанням в нас проблеми створюють інколи
такі ситуації от ми говорили про те що
дитина може перевестися що перед першим
вересням на іншу професію вірніше
написати іншу заяву а Інколи буває таке
що учень передумає першого жовтня 1
листопада вчитися на даній професії
механізм переводу з одної професії в
іншу а власне чисту технічно
[музика]
непередбачено на сьогодні на роботу
передбачено відрахування потім
включиться будь ласка на секунду
якщо дитина 1 жовтня 1 вересня почала
вчитися першого жовтня передумала
хоче і хоче перевестись на іншу на іншу
професію
то в принципі це це ж уже не це ж уже не
вступ якщо у вас на тій професії якщо на
тій професії у вас є місце є обсяг
ліцензійний до прикладу 30 а навчається
29 є одне місце є регіональне замовлення
ну тобто все складається зорі склалися
нормально і там все можна так чого не
можна це робиться наказ про переведення
тому що переведення між професіями ми
нормативно не чули що було передбачено і
тому реалізацію є де би нема на сьогодні
значить будемо думати працюю будемо
думати працювати Тому що при в принципі
в принципі Ну
теоретично це законом не ну не
заборонено Та будь ласка та подумайте
про себе такий випадки є і останнє
питання
Я його назву так випуск заднім числом
буває таке що Ми заносимо в базу
учнів на підставі не паспорта а
свідоцтва про народження
при відрахуванні всі можна операції
робити тільки на підставі паспорта
бувають таке що ми відраховуємо
достроково бо дитина не відвідує не
з'являється на навчання
і ми не можемо замовити йому свідоцтво
бо немає даних паспорта
ми його відраховуємо але документ
замовляємо тільки тоді коли він приніс
той паспорт і тоді вже в свідоцтві є
дата випуску зовсім інша
Ми не можемо заднім числом поставити
туда це називається відрахування чи
дострокової випуску достроковий випуск
тоді ви замовляєте тільки особі яка
навчається якщо вона не навчається то
поетапно вона вже здобула до
пустимо і здобув первинний розряд А на
наступний розряд перестав ходити і ми
маємо право випустити учня За рівнем
кваліфікації Рівненського
але дата відрахування буде тільки тоді
в свій досві написано коли він принесе
паспорт а він може це принести через
місяць через банк Ми не можемо це
зробити заднім числом я би казала що теж
запропонувала що теж таке треба
продумати як це технічно зробити тому що
в додатку до свідоцтва будуть писати
одні дати А на самому свідослі дата
випуску є іншою Давайте ви також
напишете на міністерство в цій формі щоб
це обговорити тому що питання
таке
документ про що посвідчення особу до
картки ви зможете внести коли воно внесе
про Терміни це вже питання Міністерства
більше
давайте
знову ж таки я буду періодично скидати
нашу ви бачили там цю Google форму ваше
питання попадає в категорію інше значить
Дорогі колеги часом ми з вами
перебираємо вже багато та тому дивіться
в мене От я зараз
вчать листі бачу Оксана родченко це
Остання людина якій ми 10 людей ще так
останній Остання людина якій ми включимо
мікрофон всі інші будь ласка пишіть
запитання в чат ми їх Я всі їх опрацюю і
запитань багато ви самі бачите це займе
скількись там часу і через кілька днів
швидше за все на наступному тижні ці
відповіді з'являться в описі увага в
описі до відео на Ютубі ну тобто
розумієте да оце наша бесіда Там будуть
всі запитання і та і та і там будуть
відповіді якщо Ну якщо якщо раптом
трапиться так що кількість символів у
цих запитань відповідях буде більше яку
дозволяє YouTube вставити то там буде
посилання на
документам чи на веб-сторінку на онлайн
документ або веб-сторінку де Де це все
почитати добре запитання це стосується і
тих всіх запитань які вже зараз тут є і
всіх тих запитань які в Ютубі є
відповіді на них всіх буде надано
в відповідь з'явиться в описі до відео
на Ютубі через кілька днів дайте нам
можливість опрацювати бо запитання Як
бачите дуже-дуже-дуже багато
так наступна в мене сурминка Віта будь
ласка
Доброго дня
от закладу 20-75 у мене таке запитання
дивіться по поводу створення конкурсних
пропозицій
Наприклад ми маємо таку професію як
слюсар з ремонту колісних транспортних
засобів ліцензований обсяг у нас 60
чоловік становить а регіональне
замовлення становить 30 чоловік от
Скажіть будь ласка чи може ми
перевиконати План не 30 дятел до нас
прийде наприклад 60 чоловік чи має ми
таке право
Так я доставав доставав ручку
перевиконання ви маєте на увазі
перевищення ліцензованого обсягу 56
і у нас 60 чоловік
замовлення по даній професії 30 ми
можемо набрати дві групи по 30 можете
першу за регіональне замовлення другу за
гроші за гроші на це базова загальна
середня освіта це на базі дев'яти класів
регіональне замовлення затверджує ваша
обласна рада ви не мені маєте задати це
запитання от а вашу обласну Раду чи вони
за це заплатять швидше за все Ні
тому тому можете набрати за гроші Ну це
якщо по-простому по простому відповідь
на ваші запитання
обсяг на бюджет ставлю ліцензійний 60
обсяг на бюджет ставлю 30 осіб так як
регіонального міста
все дякую вам тоді Та будь ласка пані
Тетяна кіна
будь ласка пані Тетяна у вас увімкнувся
мікрофоном слухаємо
Доброго дня управління освіти і наука
Волинської облдержадміністрації
Підкажіть будь ласка чи буде мати змогу
управління відслідковувати подані заяви
закладам для заповнення Форми 6w-тех які
ми подаємо щороку Міністерство на певні
звітні дати цього року на 15 липня для
відслідковування заяв по кожному закладу
або звіт загалом по області
покваліфікованому робітнику і фаховому
молодшому в розрізі
базовий і повної загальної середньої
освіти Чи буде такий функціонал є демо
для управління
переглядати подані заяви ви можете і на
собі гроші є така можливість заходити в
кожен заклад освіти і дивитись подані
заяви звітів таких непередбачено не було
такого запиту тобто якщо також
Міністерства нехай зафіксує якщо є
потреба якихось таких звітних даних по
поданих заявах також
Тетяна боренда в нас щороку Приймаємо на
кожній
не те що які є форми звітні А про те що
потрібно формувати якісь звітні дані в
їди бо для
обласних органів управління про це мова
це звіти які затверджені відомніше
статистична звітність по прийому учнів
до закладів професійно-технічної освіти
та виконання регіонального замовлення не
реалізовано тобто
якщо це тут буде онлайн і ми будемо
фіксувати всі заяви в ЄДР або то це було
безручно Коли б ми не збирали паперові
звіти а могли сформувати на 15 липня на
1 серпня і отак щоразу сформувати такі
звіт якщо є така умова що всі заяви
будуть підрахуватись в єдебо
функціоналу такого наразі немає
доціль доцільність цього створення Ну
е-е ми ми з колегами обговоримо от така
моя відповідь приблизно Тобто я не можу
вам пообіцяти що це буде включено В
наступний технічне завдання ми
обговоримо доцільність цього питання
хотіла Щиро дякую
так будь ласка пані Валентина
Доброго дня
вітаємо Скажіть будь ласка таке питання
в один навчальний заклад наскільки
професії може подати заяв учень на одну
на 5 чи взагалі на всі які є
давайте ще раз
технічна технічна реалізація зараз
те як колеги зробили дозволяє один
навчальний заклад подати скільки
завгодно заяв але ті типові правила
прийому до закладів професійної освіти
які вже затверджені але зараз проходять
процедуру юстування міністерстві юстиції
Там вказано що загальна кількість заяв
які Може одночасно подати вступник
дорівнює 5
тобто за зараз ця цифра п'ять стосується
лише кількості закладів у єддебу але в
тих типових правилах які от будуть
заюстовані буде 5 всього
це вот буквально ну буквально найближчим
часом тому я вам рекомендую навіть не
думати ні про які інші варіанти просто 5
заяв максимум
[оплески]
Так пані Валентина Я так розумію я
відповім на ваше питання
Дякую вам та
Гадяч будь ласка
сьогодні
стосовно видів підготовки первинної
перепідготовки і професійно-технічного
навчання знову ж таки на первинну
підготовку чи можна брати людину вже з
робітничою кваліфікації за власний кошт
і чи буде це первинна Чи це вже буде
перепідготовка це буде перепідготовка це
буде перепідготовка колеги підказують за
Ну за
власні гроші людина може вчитись не
завгодно Мені здається але тип навчання
буде перепідготовка
має кваліфіковану робіт
за гроші
первинна каже Пані Вікторія що за гроші
здобувача це буде первинна професійна
хоча за гроші це буде
професійно-технічне навчання тому що ми
говорили Ірина шумів на початку говорила
що якщо вже якась кваліфікація є
Тобто це вища освіта професійно-технічна
освіта або вони працювали в трудовій це
вже не первинна тобто первинна це коли
людина взагалі немає ніякої
кваліфікація тому ніякої освіти і
кваліфікації головне і тому це буде
професійно технічне навчання або
перепідготовка або як ну підвищення
кваліфікації це якщо професія А якщо
вищою освітою це професійно-технічне
навчання і
перепідготовками
А ще звіт вікові обмеження маємо
які-небудь
ми говорили вікових обмеже законом не
передбачено вікові обмеження дуже-дуже
рідко є і прописані для деяких професій
У стандартах ну бувають там
такі професії там можуть бути обмеження
але обмеження там Ну може бути не 30
років і 40 А там 60 плюс до прикладу або
щось боже о 18 при випуску при отриманні
це пов'язано з водіями і все інше
Так
значить наступний Олег будь ласка
так Доброго дня Ми не чутно більше ніж
добре прям Ага у мене таке питання якщо
заклад знаходиться в процесі
реорганізації і садок тимчасових
ліцензій вичерпано що робити в такому
випадку
Як це фахово можна вирішити
дивіться Коли наша наша колега яка
відповідає за це питання зараз відсутня
зверніться будь ласка в директорат
електронним електронної пошти для того
щоб ми могли підготувати вам відповідь
добре що таке принаймні зв'язатися з
вами добре А ще таке питання там
урахуванням змін які були прийняті у
квітні
який алгоритм дії про до переоформлення
ліцензії
поки що озвучувати алгоритм дії не буду
тому що я говорила що зараз підготовлено
міністерством проект постанови про
внесення змін до ліцензійних умов який
зараз візується ці зміни від ліцензійних
умов розміщені на сайті Міністерства
освіти у
рубриці регуляторна політика Тому що це
є авторегуляторного впливу і ми
підготували
авторегуляторного впливу і розміщено ви
можете зайти на сайт Міністерства освіти
і подивитися проект цієї постанови і
зміни які будуть вноситься до
ліцензійних умов та все прописано поки
що озвучувать я не буду буде затверджено
добре що таке питання ми ДНЗ
костянтинівське вище професійне училище
код 1959
у базі ще таке питання там буде
можливість вносити додатково вносити до
документи до заяв вступників
коли буде прийнята постанова будемо
говорити Ну ці зміни ще раз будь ласка
де саме додатково внести вносити
документи до заяв вступників якщо
заява подана ваш заклад освіти в
паперовому вигляді відповідно при
створенні заяви в базі Ви не додаєте
скан копії жодних документів якщо це
електронна заява вступник спочатку
наповнює свій електронний кабінет
відповідно москанами потім подає заяву
все інше не передбачено добре а якщо
група не набирається
тобто може ви питання хочете поставити
щодо до внесення заяв чи щодо
додаткового набору
якщо вона не набирається і частина
студентів хоче
Ну не буде далі поступати а частина хоче
перейти на іншу професію то створюється
заява за ну нова заява на професію
правильно
але дикий зв'язок між вашим попереднім
питанням про завантаження документів і
цим запитанням для чого щоб Ми зрозуміли
що саме вас цікавить
все мені мені просто цікаві цікаві були
нюанси Деякі моменти по роботі
функціонально базою ЄДР
Окей
давайте рухати далі пані Олександра
Добрий день ви мене чуєте так будь ласка
вітання від відокремленого структурного
підрозділу івано-франківський фахової
ресторанного сервісу і туризму
Національного університету харчових
технологій особливі вітання Вікторії
отівні хочемо задати такі питання
по-перше чи можна зняти правила прийому
які поставили вони були відповідно до
терміну вже зараз не пригадує до якого
так як в нас в правилах прийому
прописані інші терміни прийому
документів Наприклад ми Прописали не
було в порядку вказаних термінів
німецької Прописали свої тому для того
щоб вони співпадали з конкурсними
пропозиціями і просили би вашого дозволу
зняти буквально на годину часу якщо
можна зняти і переставити правила
прийому чи можливо якщо ви маєте на
увазі перезавантажити файл правил
прийому ви можете це зробити у вас немає
обмежень щодо
цього буде фіксуватись просто коли було
завантажено останній варіант Добре дякую
і друге питання Скажіть будь ласка щодо
військово-облікових документів так як
приймаємо і фахову молодшого бакалавру
ми знаємо що там
обов'язковоми документами є
військово-облікові документи як з
кваліфікованими робітниками Потім у нас
ми у нас нема
поточній версії правил у нас нема
обов'язково нема
ну тобто
в даному в даному на поточній версії
документів нема необхідності вносити
додавати до заяви військово-облікові
документи вступників от можливо можливо
це зміниться але конкретно зараз такого
зобов'язання немає Дякуємо гарно
так будь ласка
Я так розумію що це Харків в нас зв'язку
так Доброго дня хочу
почати зі слів подяки команді
директорату Ірині Володимирівні пані
Олексію зокрема за шалену працездатність
вчора фінальної є фол Skills сьогодні
така нагальна і потрібна очікувана
зустріч з приводу
роботи З єдемо В мене є питання таке
управлінського узагальнюючого
організаційне більше для себе уточнююча
сьогодні 28 червня Всіх вітаю з днем
Конституції а Значить скоро 1 липня Я
Хочу уточнити для себе і для всіх
присутніх У нас є рекомендації заповнити
модуль конкурсні пропозиції до першого
липня але технічно така можливість буде
доступна і після цієї дати Я правильно
розумію
так
Дякую І
попередньо говорили на це запитання
відповісти ну якби більш розлогу там
двома реченнями
логіка проста з першого з 1 липня
з'явиться можливість у дітей реєструвати
електронні кабінети якщо не буде якщо не
буде створена конкурсних пропозицій до
цього моменту дитина ваших конкурсних
пропозицій просто не побачать це це
перша частина відповіді друга частина
відповіді вона більше стосується власне
управлінців директорів закладів і
працівників департаментів є Ну дійсно є
переживання що дуже мало часу і так далі
в той же час для тих адміністраторів йде
бо у кого є такий досвід там зокрема
створення конкурсних пропозицій для
фахових перевищення і так далі ті
заклади з якими я тестував ці можливості
процедура внесення конкурсних пропозицій
зайняла годину в адміністратора тобто не
день Не два а годину
Дякую наступне питання випливло із
попереднього
нашого добові для час скажемо так до 1
грудня Минулого року були затверджені
правила прийому далі у травні цього року
приймаються регіональне замовлення в
якому є видозміни щодо переліку професій
кваліфікаційних рівнянь і так дальше на
підставі там ситуації в регіоні потреби
кваліфікованих робітниках у нас наразі
очікуємо правил прийому нових змінених
заарештованих які вже були анонсовано
Так в мене питання спільне мабуть про
ресурс вже відповіли що технічна
можливість буде змінити
інший правила прийому до директора тут
Питання в тому що
ми вносимо
процедурно
щоразу змінить зміни після того як
затвердили регіональне замовлення Там де
зміст і зміни після того як прийняли
нові правила прийом
так абсолютно правильно і
перезавантажуєте ну таке життя вносимо
зміни
кожний місяць кожних два місяці завершу
я проханням про зміни дуже прошу пане
Олексію ви нам подарували чарівну
можливість ви її команда і попередники
роботи з єдебо функціонал зростає ми це
все
вникаємо чи як це правильно сказати але
нагружаються здебільшого люди які за
штатним розписом мають інші
посади якщо можна будь ласочка на рівні
Міністерства директорату Розгляньте
питання дайте пропозицію щодо внесення
до типових штатних розписів такої посади
як адміністратора йде до чи працівник
дійдемо і так далі
ми працюємо над внесенням змін до
штатних розпису до типових штатних
розписів закладу
професійно-професійно-технічної освіти
Але для того щоб
донести додаткову Ви повинні до нас теж
звертатися тобто письмово Напишіть будь
ласка письмово для того для
обґрунтування тому що наше ґрунтування -
це є одне коли у нас є звернення ми не
обіцяємо що вони будуть прийняті ви
розумієте що це додаткові гроші що
значить змінити типові штани не можемо
помічника майстра вже три роки три роки
внести і
щоб були зміни тому але напишіть нам
Я зрозуміла як в мене зі свого боку дві
маленьких ремарки перша цей як це звання
стаханові сроку тут не лише працівники
директора та заслужили і працівники є бо
тому що
дякуємо робота
вони вони перший бастіон який стикає
після того як ми доводимо вам якісь
інструкції листи і так далі
з першим валом запитань саме вони
стикаються це перша частина моєї
відповіді а друга у нас ну зрозуміло що
там над цими штатними розписками і так
далі ви можете працювати з директоратом
але Повірте ні в кого немає на меті
навантажити людей додаткової роботою в
принципі швидше навпаки і я про це вже
сказав Та ми будемо зі свого боку зараз
починають знову ж таки починається
вступна кампанія 1 липня я попрошу
інформаційний відділ провести
широкомасштабне інформування і так далі
в соцмережах у нас це є спеціальним
молодіжний підрозділ для вже я знаю що
вони там Instagram моно ведуть там
тік-ток чи ведуть Я не знаю ну але ну
тобто робота з молоддю ведеться ми
будемо всілякої інформувати молодь з тим
що був вони самі створювали електронні
кабінети і самі заповнювали свої заяви і
це відповідно звільнить ваших людей від
необхідності виконувати цю механічну
роботу Я завжди колегам кажу вас багато
а я один кожен по одній заяви що це
заповнив і мені в 100 разів менше роботи
От тому і ну Аналогічно Я пропоную вам
налаштовувати свою роботу з тим
щоби Ну е-е там Аналогічно було
запитання А що робити якщо у нас там
лише один працівник
має має доступ до вас і так далі
заохочуйте працівників більше
комунікувати більше роз'яснення роботи
надавати і тоді це звільнить вас від
необхідності виконувати роботу Замість
замість дітей
Ну тут ско питання в контингенті в тих
ліків оскільки вони можуть бути знову ж
таки я повернусь до перших своїх
вступних слів
я пам'ятаю як були перші роки вступу
через де був заклади вищої освіти Тому
що мій рідний кум був адміністратором
Ніде в одному із закладів вищої освіти
от я бачив ці червоні очі от значить я я
пам'ятаю Це було ми з вами перший рік ми
навчимося Все буде добре ви виправимо
цифровізуємось автоматизуємось там не
знаю напише напишемо В наступні роки
аплікації будемо зі смартфона через дію
все підряд просто ну типа потрошечки
Спочатку реалізуємо це добре
і натхнення
і Пані Я вибачаюсь перед іншими перед
Світланою і Олик з сандрами зараз
секунду я відкрию час закрию і перед
Олександром Я вибачаюсь у нас
домовленість була Що пані Оксана
родченко остання будь ласка
Добрий день питання перше значить при
внесення конкурсної пропозиції у
вартість навчання ми вносимо вартість
навчання за весь курс навчання або
щомісячно по місячних
це вступна базі 11-го класу
регіональне ліцензійний обсяг принципів
регіональна 25 ми можемо 5 наприклад
набрати за
контракт тобто вартість навчання ми
вносимо за весь курс навчання тобто собі
треба вам визначити що бо вище фахового
передвищення там за рік навчання вносять
рік тобто вартість повного навчання це
групи
передвища освіта вносять за рік навчання
Тут також зробити ми
Приймемо рішення з цього приводу та і
очевидно швидше за все ми до вас
звернемось із проханням підпис цього
рядка змінити саме для тих для того щоб
це ну це трактувалося однозначно там
умовно вартість року навчання
Добре дякую наступне питання додатковий
набір зазвичай оголошують на початку
вересня а в конкурсні є такі графи їх
зараз вносити але офіційно що
повідомлення немає або буде можливість
редагувати конкурсну пропозицію у
вересні
дати додаткового набору ви зможете
внести потрібний вам час ці поля
доступні будуть для редагування
тобто у вересні так добре наступне
так добре дякую наступне питання
наприклад після зарахування після наказу
зарахування після карточки здобувачала в
собі Ти дебо тобто учень
навчається 2 тижні
додаткового набору там не об'явлена або
після додаткового набору який вже він
закінчився так розуміємо наприклад
додатковий набір
оголошено
до 1 листопада або до 1 жовтня
Закінчився термін додаткового набіру
учень після додаткового набору не виявив
бажання продовжувати навчання ми його
відраховуємо як буде реалізовано в базі
наприклад
страхування на звільнення місце
в мене
питання заяви прийшли до вас ми подавали
не подавали заяви А в мене питання А
якщо правила раніше не подавали але
можна і так і так це буде реалізовано
почитайте хвилиночку якщо вашими
правилами прийому визначено що набір вже
закінчено на підставі чого ви ще
приймаєте в них заяву
тобто він після завершення додаткового
набору не хоче навчатися ми його
відраховуємо у нас відрізняється Да він
пішов у нас з'являється звільнена місце
як це раніше було на звільнене місце ми
маємо право після вже додаткового набору
ми маємо право нормативно-правової на
звільнене місце зарахувати учня
як це буде зараз рахувати протягом
місяців протягом наступного року чи от
ну це питання до Міністерства в принципі
але ну просто цікаво якщо маєте право
якісь повинен бути обмежений період
початку навчання чого вони швидко одній
програмі ну це не початок навчання це
зарахування на звільнене місце бюджет
він прийшов у грудні наприклад У нас є
вільне місце
ми прийняли він не
підрахував техніку немає
Ні
ну то Олексій будь ласка це вже до
Міністерства питання
на це
процедурне питання Воно не про
реалізацію в єдева а в принципі тобто
вступна кампанія завершена завершена
додаткові набори завершено знову ж таки
це не до мене це до колег
Давайте давайте мабуть вам скажу рівно
те саме що і всім попереднім в такому
випадку пишіть ви нам пишіть тоді ми
зможемо підготувати тобто не отак от
видати Да там щось а більше
аргументовану відповідь підготувати
І ще одне Можна питання значить якщо
вступник подає заяву або в паперовому
або в електронному вигляді на навчанні
на базі дев'яти класів але ми бачимо по
даті народження що можливо він десь до
ще 11 класів
і він не Тобто ви розумієте так що
дорослий Ну там 25 років на базі дев'яти
класів подає заяву як ми можемо
перевірити по базі
Ukraine цієї можливості немає щоб
перевірити чи є в наявності у людини
атестатньо свідоцтва або атестат 11
класу тобто Як це можна реалізувати як
можна перевірити це
треба думати якщо ви не маєте параметрів
цього документа і цей документ у карті
фізичної особи є Де Бо відсутні тоді так
не знаю поки що треба якось організацій
кожного року задаємося цим
питанням
і ще одну я перевірити історію навчання
здобувача от на предмет наприклад
навчання у вищому навчальному закладі
якщо Він подає заяву після 11 класу на
предмет що немає навчання у вищих
коледжів згідно прийнятих
змін
пошуку фізична особа не відображається
тобто не деінфікується і як можна тоді
історію навчання переглянути якщо вона
не підтягується з фізичних осіб
питання по-перше персональних даних на
якій підставі Ви повинні перевіряти ці
навчання
запит Який сидять якраз
запитанням постійно задається
[музика]
в Старій базі була така можливість
перевірити історію навчання якщо
наприклад даже немає доступу до фізичної
особи зараз
корупція в Новій інформації вона не
передбачена але Дивіться ви маєте на
увазі до 17-го року
17-го року до 13-го року Тобто ми не
бачимо історію навчання допоки у нас
немає доступу
до розуміти якщо інші навчальним
закладом створена фізична особа Ми не
маємо доступа до
даних фізичної особи Ми також ще раз
кажу Зараз значно жорсткіше відношення
до доступу до персональних даних які не
відносяться до вашого навчання це Перше
А друге якщо це питання треба розглянути
пишіть до Міністерства і будемо
обговорювати Чи це потрібно чи це закон
і так далі це потрібно я хочу сказати це
потрібно тому що якщо
людина наступає на базі 11 класів і вона
каже що вона ніде не здобувала освіту
тобто в неї немає не профтехнічної
освіти неперевінної професійної освіти
не вищої не коледжу як я її можу
перевірити вона документів ніяких не дає
крім окрім свідоцтва про 11 класів як я
її можу перевірити на факт Як то кажуть
освіти Да правдивості її скажемо так
це тільки на
Оксани це це це питання вимагає Ну як
щойно вам пояснив пан Віктор от вимагає
не лише обговорення конкретно-технічної
реалізації а й широких консультацій з
приводу захисту персональних даних і так
далі тому воно актуальне Але для того
щоб почати це обговорювати будь ласка
напишіть нам це це вот вже прямо
Напишіть нам офіційне звернення на
директора
написати в директора
друзі це відповідь за відповіді друзі
пані Світлана пані Олександра На жаль я
не можу
вас цей ми перетягнули всі можливі дні
Дивіться що я пропоную
з приводу відповіді на ваші запитання Я
бачу
величезну кількість запитань в чаті я
там на окремі з них перевався
відповідати в процесі але їх більше і
більше тому
ще раз повторюю відповіді на всі
запитання в чаті там можливо це навіть
добре у нас буде час більш грамотно
підготуватися і більш чіткіше
сформулювати ці відповіді відповіді на
всі запитання
Буде надана в описі до відео на Ютубі
давайте от Якщо вам Якщо вам цікаво Бо
там були були запитання Що Яке Яке це
посилання зараз я прямо зараз його
копіюю ось дивіться ось ми з вами за
прямо зараз іде трансляція за посиланням
яке я кинув от в описі до цього відео
але не зараз не завтра А приблизно на
наступному тижні з'являться відповіді на
всі і ваші запитання це перша частина
відповіді друга частина відповіді Зараз
ми закінчуємо цей вебінар Там ми шукаємо
ми Щиро дякуємо за їхній час за
підкажете мені в чаті як правильно
отзывчивость бо це Я вже втомився і в
мене теж не дуже добре варить котелок ну
власне Дякуємо за участі колегам із
державного підприємства Інфоресурс пані
Марині дуже-дуже дякую пані Віктору дуже
п Віктору Дуже дякую значить моїх
відпускаємо Я виключу камеру виключи
мікрофони але при цьому сама зум кімната
ще буде доступною приблизно пів години і
ви протягом цих півгодини Можете сісти
собі подумати і написати в чат всі ваші
запитання от всі ті люди які зараз
лишилися в нас ще 520 людей Напишіть всі
свої всі свої запитання в цей час і я
закрию я закрию Цю кімнату не раніше ніж
через півгодини от я збережу ці всі
запитання і ми їх всі опрацюємо
домовились
це можна там плюсом давить ви не можете
говорити от я дякую за Ваш час Дякую за
ваше розуміння Дякую що що ви на
стерпите зрештою Да я я розумію ваші очі
коли ви читаєте що до першого числа
треба зробити конкурсний пропозиції
але зрештою разом переможемо
і сусідів і бюрократія зробимо
діджиталізоване суспільство щасливе все
всіх щиро обнімаю Вітаю за святом з ним
Конституції от Бережіть себе і до нових
зустрічей пока